all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito ibontas and thai guy
travis fresh on that thursday evening
campfire hot tub what's going on
how are we doing sir doing good uh i got
my booster so
just if you guys see me doing this
throughout the show it's just me trying
to work out the uh
shoulder make sure i can get the get it
flowing there um no i got a new monitor
it's 4k
144 hertz so it's hdmi 2.1 so i wanted
the hdmi 2 point i wanted the 4k for
consoles so i could go 4k 60. but i
wanted 144 so i could do 1440 like high
refresh and kind of count that one out
and hdr and the variable flash rate like
i
played vlog like i got some help to do
vlog runs i jumped in there and just
like wherever i turn this thing on i'm
like it looks like a different game oh
no see now you understand what the
castle plebs was trying to fully i fully
got what you did but i was just like no
like it's like the hdr and the
smoothness of like 4k like 100 frames
because i get about 100 105 at 4k
like it's so
just it's gorgeous oh my god
like
but something different so that's like
i've been enjoying that and then i'm
just like lining up because i've got
death stranding horizon zero dawn
guardians of the galaxy i've got like
some games i've been waiting that i
wanted to see on this monitor what's on
like my backlog like the pretty backlog
is coming i played a lot of little stuff
but the pretty backlog is time that's
what i've been doing reset my desk i got
like you guys will notice i'm like
looking at these guys the cameras here
one monitor here and one monitor here so
the station is set up i think pretty
complete now and sadly it's not even the
monitor that i ordered last year so or
pre-ordered that one last year was like
a 27
same stack kind of similar stats and
then aces has a 32 that finally like
they added the hdmi 2.1 to i think
pretty late in the game so i'm like well
i got this one it was supposed to ship
in like three to five weeks so i was
like okay by the time because i think my
other one's sitting in like the port of
la with all the crazy shipping stuff
yeah i think it's actually still out
there i was like okay by the time i get
the one in late december i'll have them
both at the same time see which one i
like i still don't have tracking on the
other one in this ship like a week later
so
he is giving us like the full rundown oh
yeah he give us the right thought
we got we got
i got all the tracking data and
everything
it's just been this week like it's eve
it's like not a big brand so i
pre-ordered like a crowd-funded thing
like a year ago and you had to like
finish like your deposit like in april
and then i've been waiting and now with
all the supply chain like there was a
boat in l.a it got switched on ships i'm
like this thing has been through hell i
really don't have trouble getting okay
no okay you really are you asked for it
you asked for it you may hear that man
talking we'll intro in a second travis
what are you up to man you look very
focused sir bro
yeah yeah
we were all talking about how we wear
glasses outside of podcasting and
outside of shows so we decided for one
episode we're going to be united in our
in our uh lenses so
this is what i look like in front of the
computer when i'm writing or uh you know
not trying to talk to girls or whatever
you know this is the uh
the default statement
[Music]
you can't wear glasses and be a pvp main
on a show you know it's not it doesn't
that is that you don't have hunters
i'm a pvp
all right well there you go
but you see you're looking at it
surgically right like i'm i'm like you
know like pvp mains are like the the
guys the rival you know football team
they're like yo we're going to
mess you up
really it doesn't really work if you got
the glasses on
see i like to come in under the radar
that's the thing i like coming out of
the radar so yeah low expectations
you're here it's a shark
rotation and then you just come in three
tap them slide out slide right back in
through tap the next and then tap the
next one in a one tap you know we'll
talk about that movement a second
i got a pup i got a puffer fish a little
bit you know scare off maybe twenty
percent before the battle even begins
[Laughter]
that's right i don't i don't have those
arms cocked but uh you know i can [ __ ]
talk so
um
yeah i also got my booster shot e and it
was the second most painful thing that
happened to me last week um the first
being that i reviewed a game called nerf
legends oh my god
two
i gave it a two out of ten which is
ign's lowest reviewed game of the year
and i think that was generous
i watched that review all six and a half
minutes of pain that you went through
much less what you played to record that
but i watched that and i sent him a
message i'm like you could have gone
lower i think you could have done a one
and been justified
yeah i don't know how much does that
game cost and what's this what's
breaking down it's 60 dollars it is a
full
game it is a what's that
what's the name of this game again it's
called nerf legends it's made by hasbro
it's a nerf it's a nerf shooter that
basically is like very obviously trying
to go like the fortnight vibe if you
look it up it like looks like a fortnite
clone
um
it so a one at ign the reason i didn't
give it a one a one means unbearable and
by definition a one basically doesn't
function as a game on any level this
game is halfway there
this game is halfway there it's
multiplayer actually doesn't function
you cannot play a single multiplayer
match in the game it is it does not work
um so half of their game is actually
unplayable uh the other half is the
campaign which is not unplayable it is
just a terrible experience uh and so
yeah i played through
all of the campaign
and i played through zero multiplayer
matches because you cannot play a
multiplayer match in the game it does
not work um and then and then wrote that
review so
that's probably the lowest i'll ever
usually we do not review games that are
that bad because
you know who's going to play a game that
by reputation is that bad you know it's
not really in any danger of of people's
buying it but in this case
there's a lot of uh parents out there
that are buying their kids
kid-friendly games before the holidays
and uh yeah yeah we we felt like it was
gonna be a public service to ward off
maybe a mom or a dad or two or an uncle
or an aunt who might buy this for their
uh their kid
because we don't want children to hate
their parents and if you can buy this
for your kid
that is it man you're done you're the
least cool uncle that they have like if
you buy this for their kids so um
hopefully i saved somebody sixty dollars
don't get like hazard pay for that one
or anything maybe i did not man i did
and you know what's messed up eve they
gave me other options and i chose
can you say the other options or the
what are the other options i can one of
them was the um was the uh
the league of legends game um the
the ruined king or whatever yeah yeah
the kind of story
yeah
that game actually looked good but i
don't know enough about law so i said
i'm not a good choice for that just
because i didn't i don't want to review
a game when i don't know like the
underlying lore because i know how toxic
that community is like that's the last
thing i want so i was like go find
somebody who knows more about lol for
that one i can't remember what the
second one was but i think it was it was
like
it was a sequel and a series of games i
haven't played so it was another one
where you know not every reviewer is a
fit for every game i haven't played
every single video game so uh i said
nerf legends this looks like a bad game
but it's not a sequel i don't have to
know any lore behind it i played with
nerf guns as a kid so i know enough to
review this game and i know a lot about
shooters right like as a guy who is
riding the wiki for halo infinite for
ign and covers destiny two of the best
shooters out there i'm involved with
playing this was an insult to me like as
somebody who just loves tight shooters
like playing this game was like
unbearable and you know what something
you know what's funny stuff i couldn't
put in the review because the game's so
bad you can't talk about the small bad
things you can only really have time to
talk about the big bad things so like
one of the things of the game that i
hated is that it has bloom
the game has
oh my god
in a nerf game in like in a nerf game
and this is a this is a game that's
catered that's supposed to cater towards
like younger younger kids right yes
yeah yeah well it has bloom
yeah yeah like it's crazy
too
yeah the matchmaking doesn't work yeah
it doesn't you cannot play a game uh
i was gonna tell teddy because teddy and
i talk all the time he hates all the
halo games that have bloom in them
that's like he just can't stand bloom at
all and i'm like dude imagine a two out
of ten game that has bloom and it
doesn't even make the cut of things to
complain about like i didn't even get to
talk about how the frame rate crashes on
the game all the time because that's
like not something to talk about when
the game doesn't even work like oh my
god anyway it really does sound like
this game
yeah it really does sound like this game
deserved a two out of ten you know but
just really quick too i just went to the
page you know for your review and it
just it stood out to me sometimes your
character will die and just never
respond but but this this is this is the
one right picking up healing items is
like getting punched in the ears
what is that about what is that about
it's like
that's salary
every every single time you pick up a
healing item in the game which happens
i'm not exaggerating every three seconds
or less anytime you pick up a healing
item the game goes
four times just like that super high
pitched hell of loud and if you pick up
two healing items it does it twice
staggered they do not it's not like they
consolidate it
like it'll just like do that as you pick
up multiple ones and like it got so bad
dude i literally was just like i'm not
gonna heal kill me i don't care i'll
respawn i would rather die
then pick up a healing item in this game
because i hate it so much i i would
rather there's no way
i need that particular that particularly
except by turning off all audio you can
turn up the
game that's that's one solution but yeah
fantastic dude it's nightmarish it's
nightmarish all right sounds like two
hours just fyi all of those people out
there this is the
darker side of reviewing games and being
in the games industry it's not all roses
and uh gold gold things it's there are
some bad signs so when you when you
complain about destiny i want you to
have a little perspective
a little perspective of how much worse
it could really get you know people out
there going oh destiny dead game yeah
seriously seriously no
play other games would be my suggestion
to you play other games and understand
how lucky you are
after uh r2 tangents wha what you've
been up to man
i can't even hear you you might be me
he's muted yeah
i said i can't i can't follow that up
man but um
at the end of the day i was just uh
still on my destiny vacation slowly
getting out of it now you know obviously
we got the 30th and stuff we're going to
talk about of course this amazing guest
we're going to intro in a minute but um
yeah i've just been i've been catching
up with the bat log man it's been
guardians of the galaxy for me right now
trying to get that knocked out man and
it's it's a pleasant surprise like i am
like wow so far world-class uh writing
and banter and being hilarious and um
i've been halo infinite man i've been
rocking i've been rocking and rolling
getting that on the um outside of that
little crazy uh battle pass system but
other than that the core gameplay is
there it's so fun and i gotta drop you
you're probably one of those people that
just picks up grenades and just throws
four at the same person every time
i just learned
like you look like the type i'm just
saying you look like the type i might
you don't know about grenades
that makes sense that makes sense yeah
that's my thing man so i've been loving
it man he's the soul of a titan he's
just yeah i'm playing kind of very yeah
i'm very tight-knit in halo it's
definitely the vibe
when you play halo that's why i picked
titan as my my main class in destiny is
because it's a bungee game and it looked
like master chief i was like yeah i
think a lot of people feel that same way
yeah absolutely absolutely i could i
just got mesmerized by the little space
magic at the destiny title screen that
was already just i got mesmerized but i
would have been a titan honestly but
anyway enough about us we've gone all
along e we got somebody like multiplayer
tips pages yes
that's my suggestion read it i'll give
you absolutely
but we got somebody special man we do
know
you've been hearing him in the
background
and chiming in a little bit but yeah we
got a returning guest coming back so we
gotta we gotta start the episode
officially now that was just the
pre-show antics
welcome to the last word episode number
one
175
this week we are on the precipice of
bungie celebrating 30 years in gaming
was there daring us to play wheel of
fortune and a loot cave from the years
past calling us back
even more exciting for the campfire this
week is our returning guest how do you
approach any obstacle that you face our
guest would tell you to be calm and
level-headed
start by analyzing the situation figure
out how to elevate yourself above that
obstacle and then execute that is unless
you present him with a bowl of grape
nuts in which he will knock that bowl
out of your hands as any decent human
should back
but
our guest brain runs on math and science
and his master's in engineering and time
spent as a patent examiner should clear
up any questions of his qualifications a
smart man is quite an understatement
but he's also one who enjoys honing his
skills in whatever he puts his mind to
he has a strong affinity for breaking
ankles with his movement both on the
court and in the arena so make sure you
strap on your shoes nice and tight so
let's welcome a man of the people of
science of music and chill a man who
would only stay away from death a man
who could only stay away from destiny
for about four months before it pulled
him back in with a hawkmoon ornament a
true distinguished scholar of warlock
order who will help you refine your pc
settings to make your gameplay the
smoothest or grab his legal pad to help
others improve during his community
custom teaching sessions on the weekends
wow rocking his headbands proudly and
slaying out every time he boots up the
game the one
the only ill physics mr tony how are you
doing tonight sir that is that is the
craziest
most complete introduction i've ever
heard love it love it love it thank you
so much for the warm welcome i truly
appreciate it
happy to have you back man it's it's
been
it's been a minute some things have
happened you stopped playing destiny
you're black back playing destiny um so
yeah what have you been up to since i
think it was like march or may since all
this i think it was march when we had
you or april or something yeah no it's
great to be back it's seriously great to
be back i had so much fun so much fun
the last time we were here hanging out
just kicking it and just cracking up and
uh just enjoying everything about uh you
know just just our lives right yeah i
mean not just destiny of course
um so uh since i was last here if that
was like in the spring
um we took a little bit of a bit of a
break from destiny you know um went and
played apex
legends absolutely adore that game
um
it's just the skill ceiling is so high
the i mean it was naturally the only
other game i felt
you know an affinity for moving from
destiny because destiny
i love it because there's a skill gap in
movement um and a skill gap in game gun
play and you can synergize those two to
make for some really cool plays um and
and you know it's impactful in that in
that manner you know like it's not as if
um
again it's not as if movement and it's
not as if the gun play but movement in
particular you know you can you can pair
those two together and just come up with
some really cool plays and and kind of
uh strike out your own unique play style
you know
so uh apex naturally was kind of
um you know something uh you know that
uh that drew me to apex was the movement
and the gun play the fact that you can
kind of do the same sort of thing over
there
um
much more of a competitive game
uh in the sense of
uh the balancing and how the game is set
out got to take it definitely a little
bit more seriously um it's more aim
intensive um
there's rankings you know but it's just
i mean it's just you gotta
let me let me put it this way this is
this is the way that i always think of
it for destiny pvp i could play like a
12 hour stream you know just pvp and but
probably go longer than that just fine
apex i get it i get exhausted i actually
do legitimately get exhausted it takes a
lot of focus um to try to play at a high
level and you know i i just started
people had had already been playing apex
for a couple of years by the time i'd
first started i didn't know anything
about apex beyond just the the basics
right
um and i had to kind of go from the
ground up and i feel like i made good
progress because you know me i'm gonna
play with intention and i'm playing you
know for the purpose of improvement but
of course trying to entertain folks
through stream um it was it was a
process it was a process it was a
journey i really enjoyed it still
arguably is my favorite pvp game out
right now that's that's not to say that
destiny i mean destiny is very close a
very close second uh for me and and
honestly halo i played it for the first
time the other day oh let's go that's
coming in that's coming in at a
not like a close third but a third for
sure for sure okay so um took a little
break went over to apex uh the biggest
thing about coming back to destiny was
was it was on
it was on the destiny side and it was on
the apex side so
on the destiny side destiny finally
caught up with their pvp right the devs
finally started um to make some some big
big big inroads with regards to not just
not just trials of osiris and the end
game but just pvp as a whole the
balancing
the anti-cheat that was introduced um
what else was it also the three-peaking
just some very big quality of life
updates uh that allow for replayability
without the frustration of some of these
i would say fairly basic you know fairly
basic frustrations you know that folks
um
you know
the pvp needed to be refined
the pvp needed to be caught up so
uh bungie starting to pay quite a bit of
attention to pvp started hiring more
folks for pvp
um
and just the the calms the transparency
and the calms just started becoming like
super crispy beautiful i'm loving it um
i know the community managers have
always been like top tier community
managers but they can only say as much
as
bungie tells them to say that they can
say they can only engage in a certain
way that's defined by their bosses right
so it's never been the transparency and
the comps have never been about the
community managers they've always been
top tier cause dmg et cetera et cetera
um
it's uh it's now it's now just like
they've
somebody is actually you know i'm saying
like giving them the rain somebody's
actually giving them the the ability to
to actually be um to be great at that to
to get transparent again so we've seen a
lot of transparency we've seen a lot of
attention we've seen uh the devs that
have been high for pvp being very
analytical and being very scalpel
oriented with how they're doing
balancing we've seen
new direction new direction in pvp being
defined um and uh therefore we're now
seeing changes being made to pvp
that we can we can that we can expect
and we can see
in line with that defined direction it's
just been fantastic to see the the
transition it's been fantastic to see
the transition so that's on the destiny
side on the destiny side i came back
because those were the things that were
required for me to come back that i
talked about on twitter quite a bit
yeah them defining a direction them
the making changes in line with that
direction them being transparent about
uh you know the direct uh like
the being transparent about things you
know with regards to pvp and and how
things are structured and how things are
being structured in bungie with regards
to resources being put forward to pvp
yeah and then you know the anti-cheat
etc etc um on the apex side apex is
fantastic to play
apex is fantastic to play the content
however for me at least is fairly
one-dimensional and so that wasn't the
most interesting for me to make content
for it because
over there because it's a it's a more
competitive oriented game it's basically
yo can you frag out right you know and
i'm catching up i mean i can do okay of
course but i'm catching up right
and
it's just like
what's great about destiny content is
you can make silly content you can make
you can make content about off meta you
can make competitive content you know
it's just like there's so much diversity
in the it's much easier to to strike out
your own niche with regards to unique
content you know you can be creative
with it
strike out something that nobody else is
is doing nobody else is talking about
and you or it could just be straight up
just your personality can carry through
and people will will enjoy you
doing similar content to somebody else
but your content your personality makes
it completely different
and people will be attracted to that but
in apex you're just much more limited by
the content that actually ends up
hitting you know in the community and uh
for uh for people's consumption right so
um that was the that was that was the
biggest thing between that and uh also
just
i want people to come through my stream
and i want people to
um
join my community whether in discord or
whatever else uh because we're just
enjoying each other's company too it's
not i don't need to always frag out for
us to have a good time you know people
come through and one of the cornerstones
one of the things that i love most about
my community is that's just kind of
learning about each other's day you know
i know that
you know i know that uh
you know
i don't know i don't know that jane is
is you know a physics major i know that
you know i've rock be just hitting that
pipe like 24 7.
you know it's just i know things about
people's lives we're in the adult
portion of the episode
[Laughter]
do me a favor turn yourself just up a
little just a little longer
just a tad if you can you can turn
yourself myself up
i'll try hold up if you can but um yeah
i feel it man i feel about that that's
that that is a big thing the vibe
the whole vibe of the community and
getting involved but i had to ask him a
question when he come back because um in
reference to the to the leaving part i
want to i want to i want to talk about
why was there the dramatic departure
from the stress and then she held them
back now i want to talk about falling
out of love and you know having to you
know move off a little bit with shiite
so that's the part i won't get to
because i think all of us at some point
during this
marathon of a season
aren't you doing that right now [ __ ]
well you're under you're not playing you
haven't played in months oh i've
got any better
how's he saying he sounded a little
better for you he you the audio guy
um you gotta say more than two words
okay
testing one two three how does that
sound about the same
sound
let me try to turn it up a little bit
all right yeah it's all good he's not
trying to blow us up but yes
yeah i'm taking it taking it a step at a
time how does that that sounds a little
better
with that all right i'll try to make
sure i'm small on the mic a little bit
too yeah hope you get all up on it
yeah
the question i got for you physics was
like you know i was just saying like we
all have that moment obviously it's a
long season season of the loss obviously
we knew we knew what was getting into we
knew that the content was there and i
know you said coming back
some of the things that really excited
you was the commitment to pvp and at
least them being transparent with the
messaging and what they're at least
attempting to do right but i want to
talk about before that where you kind of
fall out of love
and you're kind of like i'm looking at
apex right now because but you don't say
i want to talk about what led to that
oh distracted boyfriend meme yeah yeah
what made your neck turn
this game called boyfriend dungeon came
out and he just had to play it
we got to talk about the cheating yeah
so that that's that's that's i don't
know man the the the more i've been back
i just feel like that's like a sour
point in this community i feel like a
lot of people fell out of love with me
you know saying what i did but it was it
was just the honest it was an honest
departure it was an honest departure i
looked through that tweet where you were
quitting and they're like hey best of
luck hope like oh there must have been
some bad stuff in there too but like i
thought that's something i thought was
positive yeah yeah yeah people don't
know you're quitting destiny i don't
know gotta be dramatic that type of
thing or what oh yeah
of course of course what's up trev
i was just gonna say it's crazy to me
that you are expected to play one game
[Music]
and it's like attached to like your
identity and your opportunity
that's crazy to me if somebody was like
hey travis you have to just play one
video game forever i'd be like what kind
of like sophie's choice is this like why
why like it's the games in the street
because here's the thing i played
another game
i feel like the community
for streamers for youtubers it's a
little different but i feel like for
streamers they're coming there for you
like you're the product not the game and
then but then they they want you to only
attach yourself to a certain game and
that sort of thing i i'm just very
confused by that whole yeah well yeah i
have loyalty to the game for them to
follow you well to to a degree right
like i think i think what you just said
you know like people with the
expectation that you're going to play a
game that's that's like
my example is when i went to go play
apex my viewership most definitely
dipped strong you know
really people people oh most definitely
most definitely but i would never expect
i would never expect for every because
you know a lot of people don't
they aren't necessarily going to enjoy
watching apex
right you know and that's fair as far as
the content they ingest so people come
through anybody's stream both for the
the the for the personality but also for
what you know what game is played and
ideally we live in a world where you
know everybody's gonna stick around for
the personality and gonna be really
invested in
uh the personality and then the streamer
and if that happens then the streamer is
actually doing the best of jobs right
right but
that's never like even for variety
streamers you know like that's never
there's never you're never going to get
100 retention with that right so now we
go back to you know
like when i went to apex this is my
example people would still come through
say what's up
sub
and stick around for a little bit to
catch up and then i'd see them maybe
like next month or i'd see them next
week or something along that line i just
never had that expectation
while i agree with you you know you
would hope and i tie this to the
personality more than anything else
i would hope that folks stick around for
the personality no matter what but i
understand that folks are not
necessarily going to be invested in
watching apex versus you know something
like destiny that they might enjoy more
because even though on paper apex and
destiny pvp seem very very similar uh
they're very different in a lot of ways
too at the very least the fact that apex
is a br a battle royale that plays very
differently
than uh than kind of like the team
deathmatch type style arena style of
destiny 2. so
yeah interesting so yeah i get i get
that you would lose like a little bit if
they're not into that category game like
if you stopped playing shooters and went
and played like pokemon obviously
there's some people who are like all
right well i'm not into pokemon i don't
want to watch that but like
yeah i for i guess i'm like not the
target audience like i don't watch any
streamers to be quite honest i'm like
you know i'm like you got enough stuff
to do man yeah yeah but for me like if i
if there was a guy i liked like hanging
out with and watching his content and he
was playing a new game i'd be like oh i
got to see what he thinks about that
like i want to see the new thing so
anyway
but but then i got a question trav would
you stick or would you stick around you
know like four months in watching that
game though you know like it's one thing
same see a lot of people a lot of people
a lot of people would do exactly what
you said and and did do it exactly what
you said i got to see how tony feels
about apex let me go check in on him and
see see what his what his kind of
thoughts and views are and then based on
my opinion there a lot of people would
this is what happened so a lot of people
would do exactly that then after they
got my thoughts on it they would
actually try to see what they thought
about ingesting the con you know the
content actually actually consuming that
content actually looking at my stream
and seeing if they enjoy watching it as
much as they enjoyed watching me play
destiny and a lot of people wouldn't
uh wouldn't necessarily stick around um
a lot of people would stick around and
then you had a third category of people
that i love these people i love these
people not not to say i love them more
than other people in my community that
have stuck around with me no matter what
uh the people that would actually try
apex there were so many people that
actually got on apex and tried to give
apex a try as well absolutely um because
they saw me enjoying it because they saw
that i was playing it and or they wanted
to get in some games with me as well um
that was super super cool super super
cool you know so um but to go back to it
i completely understand if folks don't
want to necessarily um like consume you
know
apex a different game just because like
like i said on paper apex and destiny
look very similar but at the very least
the arena style versus the uh the battle
royale style is is very very different
um at the very least the the the pace of
play you know because in destiny i could
just run through like 30 people 30 40
people in a match but in apex i'm having
to play my life a little bit better
because as soon as i die as soon as i
make a like it's really punishing
mistakes in that game too like mistakes
are really punishing in that game so
therefore i make a mistake i'm right
back to the lobby and then we gotta fly
we gotta drop down again then we gotta
get we gotta loot up again and you know
it's rng involved in that um then you
have to decide whether you wanna hot
drop which hot drop means you want to
drop in the middle of like some good
loot but a lot of people are going to be
there so there's a good chance you might
take it else right off the bat or you
might be able to clean up and and and
move through the lobby or whatnot um or
do you want to like kind of uh like cold
drop a little bit or like lukewarm is
what i called it
um
yeah kind of the outskirts or maybe like
you know right by the hot drop area
there's there's options but all i'm
saying is it the pacing of it is is is
different and you definitely are it's
more punishing so if i really want to go
for a flashy play or whatnot i might i'm
most times i'm not good enough to carry
that off uh four months in you know i
was good enough
to sometimes every once in a while hot
drop and really pull off some plays
killed three and four people you know in
a row and then move through the lobby
and maybe get the dub or not but uh but
yeah it just uh you know that pacing
was uh
you know something that's kind of
nuanced but uh but it's very very
different very very different would you
like to see destiny get a battle royale
mode hell no good question well
spicy spicy no no no okay let me let me
say this let me say this let me say this
what if it's the other title they're
working on a battle royale in the
destination
i like okay so let me say this for like
like uh let me elaborate um
i like options okay i like options so if
destiny got a battle royale or
the new title that destiny is working on
is a battle royale it's it's nice to
switch between the two i'm down with
that you know as long as i have the
option to to play the arena because the
arena is probably where i'm gonna spend
the majority of my time
because uh that means i can chill a
little bit more i can't chill in apex
ain't nobody chillin
glasses on and everything yeah pretty
much the only time everybody's wearing
evidence
and apex are controller players and i'm
not knocking control easy with with
controller players you can kind of sit
back a little bit more and play it a
little more casually you know um
so tell that to the halo world champs
[Laughter]
but uh
but uh but if but keep in mind i've said
this because there does seem to be some
reputable some some credible
like information behind it apex
supposedly is gonna get
arena team deathmatch style um like
modes next season supposedly
supposedly supposedly some friends have
definitely sent um some videos over some
some information straight from devs that
have said that that is
a strong likelihood so we'll see and if
that happens i'll definitely get back on
apex and and mess around with it for a
little bit because then i wouldn't have
to be quite as invested um as i need to
be for the br in order to be again kind
of successful successful in those games
you got to frag out you gotta frag out
that's the content over on apex is you
gotta frag out so again that's the
reason why i came back but to answer
your question um
you know why did i leave destiny right
why did i leave this what was the
fallout
um
and it's just i've played destiny for
the last six seven years right destiny
pvp almost exclusively
and
in the time frame in the lifespan of
destiny 2's pvp
it just got to the point where it was
obvious that they were neglecting pvp
talk brother talk that talk
straight forward straightforward they
were neglecting pvp i tried to stick
around for as long as i possibly could i
tried to find you know a lot of people
are just like yo if you don't like the
if you don't like a game don't play it
if you don't enjoy this don't play it
and i completely agree i'm not trying to
play anything in my time whether it be
leisure otherwise i'm not trying to play
it if i'm not enjoying myself
that's that's when that's when you end
up getting toxic you know that's when
you end up being just frustrated and
talking [ __ ] on the mic and i've done
that i've done that before you know but
i try to make sure i keep that [ __ ] in
check and i try to make sure that i'm
you know like
my chat expects me to enjoy what i'm
playing and i think most chats most you
know most most communities expect you to
enjoy and it's your responsibility to
make sure that you're doing you know
doing something that you enjoy so that
it could you can have those great vibes
basically you can have those great vibes
in your stream
and so i i did my absolute best to just
try to find
any any corner of pvp
destiny pvp that i enjoyed so i stopped
playing trials because cheating was so
incredibly bad and pervasive in trials i
stopped playing trials
you know i sh i mean i just i just
played quick play like the entire the
entire time from from there on out i
played gambit i played pve as much as
possible as well it's i enjoy the both
of those things by the way i love gambit
but it just got to a point where i did i
do need to
have something in pvp and even quick
play just got just
it just
the neglect was getting out of control
it was getting out of control the
uh
the gaslighting to some degree you know
in communication the lack of
communication the lack of transparency
and again this is not on the community
managers i'm sure that they were
literally just being held
you know by bungie by executives by
whatever else but whatever direction the
company was going in with regards to pvp
they were just being held to the point
where they couldn't
and so
that that being the case that that
neglect that that that gross neglect
we're talking about
right for years and years we suffered
um i was trying to be positive i was
trying i was trying to give him as much
of opportunity as possible and it just
came down to the point where
that was about us
i literally played a game of i played a
game of trials i remember my last game
that i've been hearing let me hear it
let me get a fallout here we go last
game that i played
not only were these like i played trials
because my friend uh like really
insisted that i play with them that
weekend and i love playing with my
friend kells
and so opt on i'm like yes for you i 100
well we hopped into trials
um and we faced almost off the bat we
faced a couple cheaters that were
clearly wall hacking clearly
and egregiously aimbotting you know okay
all right all right cool cool
then we we got a couple wins straight
forward for the most part um and then
i remember the second i decided i was
gonna quit and it was it was endless
veil trials
i shot
shots i shot off two shots with my dire
promise hit them both in the head and
with the third shot it didn't land why
because that person just casually shut
off a grenade from a grenade launcher a
secondary grenade launcher not a heavy
grenade launcher a breech-loaded grenade
launcher killed me and i'm just like i'm
done i can't do this anymore man
it's not just we got the cheating we got
the the the lag half the time you know
sam we got and we got these these
weapons that it's just like
what is this balance you know where i
can't have rewarding
rewarding gun fights because i'm just
getting hit by something that
you're about to get me going let's go
that shouldn't have been even in the
game to begin with why are great
launchers in the secondary spot and pvp
in a life limited playlist being so
incredibly consistent and i can't get
consistency out of just using a normal
primary primary weapon there was nothing
that was going to stop me from getting
killed right there literally no a pulse
rifle i would have died a hand cannon i
would have died a scout rifle i would
have died
like like dog you know and then we're
not even going to get into stasis and
why
why it was so pervasive on drop where i
was so pervasive on drop and the fact
that it was pay to win because if you
didn't buy
that if you didn't buy beyond light you
didn't have access to stasis
was literally winning
winning
games for for how long for months you
know for months how did that even get
through i'm trying not to slam this on
the table i could feel it i could feel
it i could feel it i don't know
me you didn't talk so i needed this is
the healing right so like i needed to
know the pain the suffering and then
what led you and then now where he's
gonna go you know
to to coming back and and seeing that
the attention being paid at at least
right at least some of the trans people
oh boy shake it i know brother you've
been through it you've been doing it
i was there i was there and trav was
there you know we all were there and we
would talk about it of course we would
just be like look you know what is going
on why is it and you said it so
eloquently which was
we don't want to blame community
managers because they are being
instructed on what they can put out 100
but it was clear it was an impact it was
almost like a a silence a silencing of
that part of the game as far as what are
we going to talk about with the
community and it's just so good to see
at least at the bare minimum the the
focus was at least coming back so that's
good to see that at least that kind of
got your eye looking like okay now and
now we're getting into the 30th
anniversary but i'm going to give it to
driving e i just had to get that from
you but i wanted to do it and i got to
say one more thing i'll say one more
thing too it's just like
me like like i
like twitter is my other twitter is my
other big platform you know what i'm
saying like my discord is also like a
close third of that but twitter is my
miss my platform that like i'm a writer
more than anything else i love writing
and i love like elaborating and
articulating through good writing
through good thoughtful writing on stuff
and so
um
you know i tried for so long just to
break it down you know this is what we
need you know
like a really good example is it is
obvious that there is no direction right
now for pvp like changes are just being
made changes are just being made
like this you know
yeah we're just throwing things at the
wall and seeing kind of what sticks but
it almost seemed like half the time they
didn't even care what stuck it's just
just throwing stuff at the wall you know
and so i try to yo we need a firm
direction so that we at least have
expectations so that when say for
example you want that direction to be
maybe in a direction that i don't
personally care for okay cool but at
least i now have an expectation patient
yes you know at least i now have an
expectation so i don't have to guess
i don't have to guess one way or the
other on why this change is being made i
have an expectation okay well this is
the direction and now i can make a firm
decision myself
on whether i want to play it because i
know what direction
you know this is not a surprise anymore
right
and so
like i guess i guess what i wanted to
kind of come back around to is the fact
that
like it just seemed like i just get i
just got so much hate you know i just
got so much hate and most definitely i
just got so much hate because people
this is why like literally the first
statement that is in my twitter bio says
think critically you know
people people just don't want to they
they refuse to think critically about
this stuff and it's just like look
like i'm i'm
like i try my best to give a very
balanced perspective when i talk about
things i try to make sure that i give
praise and kudos anywhere possible that
i can for bungie devs etc etc and
there's plenty plenty of plenty of
positive stuff
to shout that to shout out i would say
arguably more positive stuff
ever to shout out because because we're
talking about pvp right now but you know
but but but pve
for like a minute
like bungie been killing it with pvp a
pve for like a minute you know but it
but that only made the neglect to pvp
even more glaring yes you know yes so
it's just like so i just wanna you know
like i'll come to a point right here
just by saying like the amount of like
just just just man yeah
you know
me just but me by me just standing up
for pvp trying to be as respectful
trying to be as thoughtful as sensitive
you know in my feedback as possible it's
just ah
you know there's very little nuance on
the internet and it goes for a lot of
topics and it's like people get a lot
more heated about games but it's like i
mean i've talked to travis and cog about
stuff offline it's like you can't have a
discussion on the internet much less on
twitter about anything that's actually
that matters and this is people getting
heated and pissed off over a game that
should be fun and entertaining and as
you guys have said it's like there are
points where it's like oh i'm gonna
leave it's like oh it came back it's
like so he had a change of heart no big
deal but also it's like he's allowed to
have
i don't think anybody can go through
your twitter and say
you've like gone off the rails or like
you know had a completely ridiculous
take it's like do you see how many were
like the discussion topics like the well
thought out bullet point list here this
guy does just to be like here this is
the one thing i want to talk about today
this this this cause of this maybe this
but we could do it in this way if we
made these changes it's like that's
actually thoughtful constructive
criticism as opposed to you guys are all
terrible people it's like and then the
attacks that developers get as well is
just personal attacks yeah
so it's like people getting personal
attacks and then there's very little
nuance to even a decent discussion i
mean it's like travis and i like joked
about one thing at one point i don't
want to bring it back up again but it's
just like stuff that was going on kind
of halfway across the world it's like
there's no way you could talk about that
stuff with any bit of nuance and not
just get like
absolutely lit up on twitter so
no it's like it's really sad that having
an opinion
is taken so poorly being is that it's
like it can be opinion there can be some
facts there can be some decent
discussion and some of these things but
usually twitter's just set on fire half
the time if it's not their opinion the
match is yours and it's really sad
yeah well i just i just
yeah most definitely i just you know
even just coming back i mean i was very
very detailed in both why i left when i
left i was very detailed in the fact
that it was not a crazy reflection on
bungie as a company and things like that
i wanted to make sure that this was it
wasn't something where i was i was just
like people maybe expecting me just to
go off on the rails on bungie like i
literally said i quit the game in like
one tweet but the successive like maybe
four or five six tweets or something
like that was just praise on everything
that i love about bungie and about the
game just in general um and i was trying
to make sure that i balanced that
because i you know like it's just not
necessary like i said i quit so what's
like what's and i've already said what
my prop my issue is kind of what the
game are so like there's no reason to
continue to go with that and then even
coming back
like i made sure to say why exactly i
came back which by the way was in line
with exactly what i requested
when i left
you know like those they were the exact
i told them cheating free peaking you
know what i'm saying like like
matchmaking investing more in pvp
resources a direction like literally all
of that stuff and that's what was
required for me to come back and that's
what i when i came back and then i
confirmed again that those were the
things died for our patches that's it
brother put it up we took the apex
sacrifice so we can see pvp grow
[Music]
well well said and i i agree you know
it's okay to have constructive criticism
i think you've been respectful and and
how you handle it and i just think it's
one of those things where just like at
the end of the day
you know people have to separate the
emotionality because what it is they
they love the game so much and they they
love you and they probably took it
internalize it too personal you
yeah yeah
and that that's just what it is and what
i what i've learned with twitter
specifically that's why i like what we
do last word because it's like this is
the format to have those debates and
stuff with people because to me i'm only
going to engage you
if i care about you
you know what i said if i care about we
going back that means i can because i
respect you enough that i feel hey you
know we could have an intelligent
discussion at the end of the day we can
agree to disagree but at least i know
it'll be respected unfortunately
fortunately with twitter the nuance and
then some people it's just nasty and
malicious man you know what i'm saying
and it's just not worth it yeah and i
failed the internet yeah i've just
learned to abstain from dealing with
those people because he's just trying to
get it get a reaction out of you you
know what i mean
yeah we got a big 12 so we may as well
jump into that one a little bit later
into the podcast so
uh first thing i do want to touch on
before we get into all the game stuff
that we've got going on is uh game to
give and that is the charity event that
is going on right now um there's going
to be links pretty much everywhere i've
got one because i've been kind of part
of this thing for the last couple of
years
and it's their charity event for kind of
the holiday season and they're doing it
for basically a couple of weeks and by
donating towards the bungee foundation
which does everything from working with
the children's miracle network of
hospitals st jude's and honestly they've
expanded it so much more to cover
basically a lot more causes if you guys
have seen
but the pretty much the way they kind of
wrap it up is we are people-focused
organization that builds and empowers
our community to improve the health and
well-being of children
uplift the rights of all individuals and
communities and provide aid in times of
crisis and pretty much wraps up
everything they go for they've done the
you know the shirts when you were
helping i think it was like nepal with
the earthquake
um you've obviously seen the black lives
matter stuff that they did before um you
actually saw the ceo out there marching
in seattle and stuff like that and then
also always working for basically the
little lights and the children so they
are doing that once again and depending
on how much you donate up to 50 bucks
you can get an in-game ship multiplayer
emote couple emblems things like that um
and then depending on you know if you
catch somebody doing a stream they may
have some incentives and stuff like that
i am actually going to be doing a
featured stream for that it's going to
be monday the 13th so about a week and a
half from now so it'll be like 68. um
trying to figure out what my incentives
are going to be kind of leading up to
that one i'm trying to narrow those down
this weekend
but overall it's just that's one of
those things when it comes to the
community and you said this as well tony
is like
when it comes to what bungie the
community managers and when this
community comes together to do good
things it is pretty much second to none
when they do these charity drives when
you see the amount that people are doing
i know skaro did his was kind of an
early stream to kick some of this stuff
up thousands and thousands and thousands
of dollars get like raised for these
really really good causes yeah so i
wanted to make sure that you guys all
know a new rat i'm thinking about that
um
[Music]
push it up so you come back i'm trying
to figure out because i was honestly
wondering because
like been lifting some but i also like
kind of got the heavy bag downstairs got
a rowing machine and i was kind of
trying to decide depending on how much
gets donated like how long a workout
could be or how long rounds could be and
actually just kind of do that on stream
and depending on how much more people
donate so i'm trying to figure out if i
can do that mathematically so i don't
die like if people donate a lot when i
don't just like i'm just like a lump on
the floor
it's like once the bag it's like i can't
lift my arms anymore like
so i'm trying to figure out if i can
find a good number for that push-up per
dollar
oh no i would die i would die
push-up sadly is something i'm very weak
at for whatever reason like i could
squat yes actually
yeah for some reason like my push-up
endurance like actually i'm
not that strong at bench but i was like
i'm okay kind of around body weight is
where i maxed recently um
but like push-up endurance is not
something i'm actually that good at i
could air squat
probably longer than a lot of like a lot
of people just sit there and just do air
squats or decent
yeah those are real yeah i was like i
could go for a while on those but no
push-ups and i've been working on them
off and on but it's just one of those
things it's yeah
so like i would have to i would have to
mix it up i'd be like all right so some
squats and push ups and sit up some bag
work some wrong and just like try and
have a rotation going so i could survive
it but
check out any of the featured streamers
um monday the 13th will be mine but if
you're just looking to donate uh it's a
really good cause and you get stuff in
game and destiny as well so it's always
it's one of those things i wanted to
make sure we shout out before we get too
far away from basically everything
that's going to be in-game yeah i'll
make i'll make one point as well um you
know uh the charities like so so
obviously bungie does a great job with
uh picking
the causes you know that they end up um
you know contributing towards or uh
putting on blast you know giving
exposure too but they they also do like
something that a lot of people probably
don't
uh don't recognize they they pick great
charities themselves yes like the actual
organizations themselves all charities
are not made equal no you know it's
something that i've recognized for a
long time just in in you know i'm a
little bit older right so between the
charities that you know i end up raising
money for or that i end up giving money
you know to over the years
i always go by websites like charity
navigator and just kind of check out how
they end up spending their money
and how effective they are in their
mission based on the money that uh that
we end up giving to basically where that
where that money goes where that money
goes right the organizations that that
bungie ends up partnering with
fantastic to they do their homework they
do their homework i haven't seen it i
haven't seen a time where they haven't
done their homework where i'm just like
oh that organization is a little sketchy
or whatnot they do their homework it's
really really great so i gotta give like
definite kudos kudos to them on that and
i'll say the last thing don't give to
the red cross
horrible organization
they do a poor job they do a poor job
with routing the money that you give
them just fyi
respectfully said well good to know see
you've heard it right here you know
where it should go and also apparently
one place you should
very much research before you give to
there you go that's i'm not going to say
either way but that's it yeah yeah
that's they could agree don't take my
words
do your research
uh that little bit out of the way um
definitely make sure you guys check that
out though so extremely good cause we
got a little um
i don't know
if we've ever had a season like this
trials is back to discuss
once again um trials labs freelance is
coming back
and
basically they said it's going to have
one little change
so freelance is going to be trials this
weekend we'll have the node up there for
trials labs
as it is labs
they said the only thing is you only
have to own beyond light and b1290 you
don't have to do the trials intro quest
i don't remember what the trials intro
question is at this point
we all probably like walked up we're
like check i think it's a certain amount
of pvp that you have to do to before you
can do trials i don't think you have to
hit you have to hit uh you have to do
one valley i was asking the same thing
in the chat my chat a little bit earlier
i think you have to do a valor reset at
least once okay oh okay that's actually
a decent amount of time in there that's
a decent amount of time actually
yeah this one does not require that but
does require owning beyond light and
being 1290 of course everything else
still matters um but i kind of wanted to
go to you first
and see
what are your thoughts on
freelance existing would you like to see
it stay do you like it do you not were
you out on trials freelance just being a
thing
i absolutely love charles freelance
absolutely adore it
um ah man
where to start so
so i'll start i'll start at the at the
end first um
uh not requiring people to
do uh do the trials quest or whatnot i
see where they're going with that you
know bungie
the direction that bungie has taken
which is fantastic uh at the beginning
of the season is to get that population
as high as possible but also balancing
that we're trying to eliminate cheating
and kind of like the bad actors and
things like that
um and so this is uh another
another kind of uh
you know decision that's in the vein of
trying to get that population up which
obviously is going to dip uh later into
what is what is mounting up to be a
fairly long season yeah so um i'm
interested to see how it ends up playing
out obviously it was kind of a gate that
was put there in order to uh
de-incentivize you know new accounts
coming in uh which a lot of times end up
being bad actors cheaters and things
like that who just you know start up a
new account and just go again we just go
again right so um but i do like i said i
see that the population is dipping a
little bit and whenever population is
low it always sucks for the people who
are actually still playing the game
myself included uh trials
so i'm interested to see where it goes
happy with the change and we'll just see
how it plays out i see obviously that
you know the direction they're trying to
take with it
as far as freelance love love love love
it um it's unfortunate that it ends up
splitting the playlist what a lot of
people don't know about trials and kind
of like split playlists is there's a
bunch of like little mini pools that
folks don't recognize that folks don't
know
you know cross play is not
100 percent right so there's still going
to be little pockets and little pools
where you i'm not going to have access
to and somebody else is never going to
have access to me and things like that
um
so
you know with there being uh you know
card based matchmaking um with there
being flawless pool on sunday with there
being these little mini pools that folks
don't even kind of recognize exist based
on platform and everything else um
uh most definitely pools
there's a whole bunch of yeah yep yep
um you know it sucks that uh the
population gets split but it's fantastic
that it's freelance and nobody has to
play against stacks nobody has to play
against teams so it's it's it has been a
very well received playlist very well
received from what i've seen people
generally love it um myself included
um
it's just unfortunate that even when
freelance came around the first time it
would it actually that the threes
playlist that the normal playlist got
hit pretty hard with regards to
connections and matchmaking times
so that's something definitely to kind
of keep in mind for everybody that even
wind population is at a pretty decent
point adding in freelance um you know
kind of hits the regular playlist kind
of hard so does that mean that we're
even going to be able to have a
freelance playlist
uh even when population is high i i
don't know you know the the answer to
that i don't know the answer to that
it'll be interesting but the question
for
everybody else
um
with regards to freelance whether you
whether you like it and how much you'd
like to see it but would you is there a
time frame as the splitting of the
playlist especially late in the season
we don't know how long the seasons will
be things of that nature
is there a point where it's like every
other week every three weeks like is
there a frequency where you think it
would be
nice to have for the people who want to
play and not face the three stacks but
also
give enough balance to like the general
population being together so it's
healthy most of the times there are
amount of times that you guys would
think freelance would be
healthy to see not too much not too
little is there a magic number you guys
could put it on travis
you're you're not you're noodling right
now um
yeah i don't really um
it would sort of depend on their numbers
i feel like they know their player bases
and that sort of thing but
i kind of wonder if like the
population's low enough if they really
think freelance is worthy playlist
then maybe they should alternate maybe
there should just be a weekend where you
can only play freelance
you know that's a game mode because uh
other games do that like and halo is one
of them like one of the rotating
playlists in halo is ffa playlist and
or you know that which is essentially
like a no
no parties yeah it's free for all you
can't party up and so it would be pretty
easy for them to do that if they felt
that that was in their best interest
but from a game design perspective i
feel like trials is very clearly meant
to be played with teams and you can see
that just by the fact that bungie says
don't expect to go flawless if you play
in the matchmaking playlist you can see
just in the game mode and the fact that
call-outs and all the stuff that we were
complaining about a couple weeks ago
when you have like a blueberry on your
team or when you're not in a full stack
and there's miscommunication or you have
one guy who's a who's a
a wild a wild cannon loose cannon right
uh that's never like a good uh a good
feeling to have um so i kind of feel
like it's probably not part of the game
design and it'll always be kind of like
an add-on that they can do when they
feel like they can right and that if it
were going to interfere with the
integrity of the playlist they'd
probably just turn it off but i don't
feel like it's ever going to because the
freelance playlist tends to increase the
amount of people who are playing trials
that said it probably
takes some people out of the
non-freelance playlist of trials because
there's some people who are just like
well why would i play with a full team
if i don't have to go through the hassle
of getting my whole team together and
all that stuff
um
so yeah i i think we probably don't know
enough to diagnose the problem but i
would just say from like
a philosophical standpoint i don't see
it ever being more than kind of like a
an add-on you know to to like the the
core playlist
yeah i mean
you know i've always been a fan of
freelance freelance only from the
standpoint of
i know everybody else is in the same
situation as me right because to me the
only problem with the
matchmaking trials one of the problems
with the matchmaking trials was just you
know the inevitability of facing that
other team and you know they're a full
three and you know you know or they at
least have two and your odds of winning
pretty much you feel goes down when
you're playing against a coordinated
unit so
you know i think it's interesting that
they decide to bring it back
almost as a
population increase device
you know be like okay whether it be you
know internally they saw something like
okay let's bring it back because it's
clearly
getting people to play i i think that
they must have some type of data that's
showing them hey
when we have it out there more people
are playing not not necessarily what i
know yeah i know you're part of this car
because you told me a story yourself
right of you actually meeting people and
then you guys actually linking up
because you had a good run together with
strangers that you would have never
played with if freelance didn't exist so
yeah i think right now it's we don't
have enough data from them on the number
side
i am curious on that but all this being
said you know obviously i'm a fan of it
but i'm still
of the mindset and i'm always gonna die
on it is that you know this is great
but i need rewards and for me you know
just selfishly speaking
i got marie's regret you know i i've got
the role i want i got firing line i got
a vorpal on stash you know what i mean i
i got the 120 you know the igneous i got
a great what is it shariah's wrath like
i'm lit like
yeah god we're like god rolls like i'm
lit so you know it's not their fault i
know they're they're messing around
they're still tweaking they're still
finding that balance and stuff like that
but to me the way i'm going to judge
them and i'm always going to you know
down it is for which queen like when it
comes back again
i would like a full slate of rewards you
know so that that investment and in
their defense this is a long season i
get it that's why i'm not going crazy i
knew coming in what this was i'm like
all right y'all figuring out yeah you're
messing around with the meta but please
i don't want it to be a situation where
next season
it's the same
list and then one more gun plus reads
regret like we really need it including
the armor sets right we want every
season i want that that same dedication
that pve gets with a raid and raid armor
and raid loot i want the same dedication
for trials with trials loot and trial
weapons and then for the most part i'll
be fine you know so you know that's
where i'm at with it i was like okay
cool you know we'll see what about you
yeah yeah um
i was gonna say like for me it's
i'm very glad that freelance is there
for me because it's been i've reset my
um
rank i've reset my reputation whole
thing all 16
twice with saint now
just because it's been an option for me
to go in there
like without anybody whether i'm sitting
here for i got an hour to play i don't
have enough time to meet people up and
it's just like i can boot it up and i
can try now is my window loss ratio bad
yeah i'm probably like maybe a third
but
would my win-loss ratio be a little more
reasonable if i knew half the time when
i like booted up a game and i hit you on
my keyboard to see is there a three
stack in there and i see it and i'm like
son of a now granted
every so often you beat one of those and
actually feels a little better because
like a couple people here and you're
like all right hey we just we wanted one
two and two okay we can we can do this
you start stepping up a little bit and
you're like playing a little more
cautious like sticking with your
teammates and
sometimes and those moments where you do
have the good games against like the
three stacks you're like well they may
not be the best three stack and maybe i
got god tier on my side who knows but
i had some i had one match that we were
down i think
three like 0.304 and somehow brought one
of them back i don't even know how it
happened like had some fun ones but the
best part i got to tell the story was
i was just streaming trials like working
on my wins
um
and then all of a sudden somebody and i
was like man
like that team just destroyed us like
annihilated like i may as well just been
like a bug on the ground and they
stepped on me just squashed like no
challenge at all
and it was like maybe an hour later or
something and they came through and said
hey that was me and your game earlier
and i looked up the name
and looked up on trials report
400 times flawless his teammate was 200
times flawless and he's like yeah he's
like dude my teammate is like god you're
sniping or what like and i was like okay
and i don't know if it's even the same
day he may have even like looked me up
later he said he looked me up on like
destiny theater or something he's like
and he actually said yeah meshuggah um
and he said he'll look up people if the
streamers are like cool and reach out
and say hey do you want to you know like
do you want to come run with us okay
backpack actually yeah but he's like and
that's why it's like his he'll look
through and find people's like because
he may be carrying or helping somebody
and then he goes through and stomps on
people and he looks through and saw
somebody was a streamer and he'd get to
reach out to him he'll be like
hey it's like big or small it's like if
you're cool you up for this so it's like
it jumped in
i've now gone flawless for one time in
destiny 2. so i went to the lighthouse
yeah what's the tweet up did i put the
tweet out too i see
no
[Music]
like every angle
but i actually i had a couple clutch
moments i had a good super shut down
um
had a couple like one or two doubles um
and that's kind of one of those things
too that it's
it's not something everybody gets a
chance to do but it's like when you play
with better people
you won't always but you actually tend
to like step up yeah as opposed to when
like crappy
like crazy guy runs straight into like a
cannon and just gets his head shot off
and you're like you're you almost seem
to fall down at that point it's weird
like you can only make up so much but if
somebody else is there who's actually
doing well then you're like okay now i'm
sticking with them i'm being a little
better about peeking or getting my shots
like you feel like you're playing better
with the better skill and it's like it's
mostly them doing it and i'm kind of
along for the ride but
i also feel like i had a couple moments
i was like okay it's like radar's over
here hey we're getting ready for a flank
pop the super they did two we traded
supers and that's what saved that round
but that guy at the same time two up
just him goes in and just slugged like
crits like crazy dude just pulled off
some shots i watched it it's like
i'm glad you're on the i'm i'm on my
side because yeah there were some shots
they did
and they're sitting there just like and
i love the people who are usually that
good
played with one or two others that have
been like this
could like read you a book while they're
playing because it's such a chill
activity they don't even they're just
like
whatever yeah they do you know whatever
a bam bam just got like godzilla shots
going off i'm going
cool i'm over here like
yeah
don't get picked don't get picked yeah
i'm like okay yeah and you get later i'm
like my super's like almost there i'm
like okay i'm staying back i'm gonna
wait for my super so i cannot like
totally waste it and get picked and be
like okay they're peeking out of sea i
like like really cautious in there over
there like yeah whatever bam here's a
sniper shot run around the corner i'll
pop my super two down i'm like i just
stood here the whole time good job
but it was that was it was a lot of fun
that was me when when when i took uh
addict to
super casual we were just talking about
other stuff while we were just watching
not at all paying attention
wait was that seven wins
and he was like he's like guys i can't
believe you were talking that whole time
because he didn't say a word the whole
game he was just like like sitting there
like he's
going to lose
he hasn't been he hasn't been he told me
about it he's like yeah chap got me
there man i was asked what's up
i was like wow lord addict's like really
quiet when he's not on stream
so not talkative stranger
different hello he's different but yeah
definitely
he he he listens to that yeah it was
mostly desperado messenger i am lucky
enough to have one of those so can't
argue there okay once or twice like i
use that actual like proc but most of
the time it's just like a ranged pulse
that i feel pretty consistent with and
then started using shires more actually
i found it one it's but not you know
mine's not god's here but kind of that
alternate it's like the shotguns it gets
close it's like they close it and i'm
dead but it's like it's got that
mid-range that i'm actually getting a
little more comfortable with that i'm
like yeah so yeah yeah show yours is
amazing amazing seriously you really
don't need to have like
a god-tier shot yours that's the great
thing about it in order for it to be a
fairly consistent weapon you've got some
decent perks on the end you've got maybe
like one or two range perks and you're
pretty much gucci because it's got 17
zoom and the zoom is is what matters the
most on smgs it's not literally any
other perk will always fi you know like
uh fall second to what zoom the smg has
and if it has got to resume like
sharira's if it has god tier zoom like
multi mach
then you can generally make something of
it with a decent role
yeah yeah that was cool but that's like
to kind of go back to what we were
talking about in the first place with
freelance
the times when i do start a match and i
pull up the roster and i'm like three
singles versus three people together
whether it's friday saturday sunday
monday this is never in the flawless
pool because sunday and monday i'm still
never there
um
the times i see those threes just really
sink my heart just a little bit because
i'm like yeah here we go
and the fact that like that's why for me
that's why i was like i don't know as
you said tr as you said travis whether
it's like they alternate the node back
and forth to be like everybody's in
threes or just you know whatever option
or it's everybody solos so it's always
like one or the other as you said the
splitting's kind of hard but i would
like to see it
every two to three weeks for me at least
so when i know it's not too long of a
wait i'm gonna get that freelance chance
again because i do like because there's
enough solo people i keep matching on my
team with then i know somebody would
benefit from that because there's enough
threes out there but there's enough
solos and i don't know what it is like
it's hard i rarely see like the two and
the one like i'm rarely paired with two
against the three yeah i don't know
what it is like it's one one one and
three stack one one one three stack i'm
like
that always can i not and then finally
you see everybody's by yourself i'm like
oh okay okay we can we can have a game
and it's like those are the games when
i'm probably a little closer to 50 50
and that's why freelance for me is more
fun because every time i start a match i
know in my head
that i'm like i'm already starting it's
like everybody's random it's like it
could go either way it's not like
odds are against me from the beginning
and that's just one of those things and
that could be me going into the bad
mindset which is totally fair for a
different thing so because some games i
have lot one but that coordination is a
thing that's gonna give you a pretty
good advantage if you're like last point
i'll say before we move on um i want to
give travis flowers because
i've been playing a lot of um
competitive halo now and
it's it says something when you see that
nice little ranking
but you see that little ranking
oh
these dudes in my bracket you know what
i said and i'm like yeah and i wish
that's the and the other thing that's
what it needs yeah
yeah i sort of reached enlightenment
with destiny's pvp after
being so close to halo's multiplayer
working
because
once you really get in like under the
skin of a game that does multiplayer the
multiplayer not even i'm not talking
about the sandbox and the gunplay
obviously that's great too i'm talking
about the the ecosystem is really really
solid it kind of made me start to think
about destiny in a different way of like
kind of analyzing we had we haven't met
in another week so it's been two weeks
since our last episode yeah in that time
i've just been like face first in halo
infinite multiplayer
why aren't why aren't there sandbox why
aren't there playlists right that
there's playlists that rotate and out
but they're only on social so like
why is it just trials every weekend
shouldn't there be a weekend playlist
and sometimes it's trials which is this
3v3 mode where you have to bring your
own team and other times it's a like uh
competitive mode that's everybody's you
know freelance and maybe another time
it's like because for us trials is
i don't even know what trials is right
now because if you think about it in
terms of halo
trials objective and trials 3v3
deathmatch would be separate game modes
before i think of them in destiny as one
that's one thing we think of it as like
oh it's trials but this time there's
objectives it's like okay well then
that's not trials like that's a separate
game mode it should have a different
name so there should be trials freelance
and that has that has its own playlist
or it rotates out on some weekends
there's trials classic which is you know
the format we're used to there's trials
objective modes like there should be
separate game modes and it's it kind of
blew my mind that we don't think of
playlists that way in destiny there's
comp and comp is just one game mode and
you know it's always the same thing and
it's
just the way that they've created
multiplayer buckets is so
backwards in my opinion and it kind of
yeah it's just very um basic and it
allows it allows for that stagnation
that tony was talking about he
experienced and kind of the reason he
left because there is no kind of like
nuance and constantly changing and oh
this
to us the big events in destiny are oh
iron banner's here oh well what's iron
banner well it's the same exact game
mode except for this time we earn
different rewards that's not a that's
not a game mode you know what i mean
like they're i just can't on a game mode
that's not a difference yeah i'm sorry
i became obsessed with how well halo has
its playlists and the way it identifies
different games and something else that
destiny could really learn from
isn't afraid to have silly game modes
like captains
yeah like an oddball and just the stupid
like stuff
like four years in and we don't have
that stuff like why did why did games
decide to get more boring with their
multiplayer modes over time because they
used to just be crazy with all the
different modes they'd offer so you're
on fire with that because you got to be
thinking
the closest i remember destiny to that
was d1
and i remember you listen you watch the
12 and it's like yo iron band is going
to be like i remember iron banner death
match was a thing a regular clash
classes this week
you know what i'm saying like yo rift is
this week you know what i'm saying and i
think
my my guess is that
for whatever pushback the community
because let's be honest the majority
love control i mean it's just it is what
it is right we we it is a maybe the
metrics show it whatever
and i remember there would be like many
revolts in the community i'm not playing
this week because it's this
like yeah it gets so boring though i
know
it makes you appreciate the mode you
like when it come around you don't say
but i mean yeah but that's kind of thing
it's like you take the oddballs you take
the capture the flags you take rift you
take clash even like to see clash of
iron banner and d2 would be like oh my
god like it's just clash
can you imagine
in a totally different way can you
imagine if they did iron banner momentum
control with the way that gun with the
stuff it's more guns
quick like different sandbox field just
to mess with everybody and they'd be
like oh god it's all scout rifles but
like just to make it feel different
because you said it's control with some
paint that's all iron banner is and it's
like control with some paint and like
the absolute worst reward system right
now and they've said it's somewhere on a
list but it's not high on the list and
the fact that there's like no direct
path after the loot there's no like what
they did for trials yeah
do that to saladin at least for now to
give your
some consistency of like hey if i want
to spend 20 tokens on this one weapon
it's at least a roll on this one not
20 000 drops later i'm out of tokens and
i didn't even get one of what i was
thinking of as well e the last time
destiny had a interesting
uh
temporary like limited time event
playlist it was because they broke the
laser
yes
and we have lasers
destiny's version of creating a limited
time event with special rules is they
they make a mistake and then everybody
just jumps on the meta for like a
weekend until they fix it but like
imagine if they just did like that
imagine if they just did a laser tag
weekend where you could only use laser
weapons or like they did like all power
weapons weekend or something crazy like
we got fiesta before the game halo
infinite is even out and that's like a
crazy ball so i love that
i love you guys
animate him do it one time i heard
banner mayhem
but it's fun and who cares because you
don't really care about iron banner
anyway have fun with it yeah do i do
iron banner snipers only do iron banners
no shields you know like they have
people
they have the ability to lock down
because you can do scorch so they can be
like this is all you get to use
they could literally just lock you into
one weapon you can't switch and just be
like hey everybody uses
whatever like that's what it still burns
me that private matches are not custom
because i know you guys are waiting on
forge which is another thing that will
help halo which probably can't get here
soon enough but that's going to be nine
months away who knows how long forge is
going to be um
but the cusp like why we still don't
have a way to do custom building yeah
you can use this in this slot and this
and the [ __ ] and that's it and you pick
the perks and just set it up and
everybody has like shoddy snipers or
anything that's like creating some of
the best modes by having the community
do it sorry yeah no it's just going to
say i played split gate a little bit for
especially for that for the flavor but i
was like i was playing it and they have
you know it's like swat headshot's a
one-hit kill and i'm like you know a
little pulse rifle and it's kind of like
your dmt is a one-hit drop and you're
just like i'm like picking off heads and
i hit a 10 kill streak and it's probably
half bots but i was like
why is this stuff not in there and
you're saying halos just open your eyes
to the same thing i'm like destiny has
the option
and it's just like at one point just
lock it out you're just stuck with these
two things that's all you get to use
right now period yeah i don't know if
something with like the code in the back
end they can't like lock out your
current weapons that you take in but
they do it with other things there's got
to be a way and that would open up a lot
of they're having you they're using labs
for trials they need to use labs for
that type of stuff yeah because they've
kind of dropped that ball you know you
guys are talking about a tougher formula
right
it's a tougher formula so we're talking
about like replayability we're talking
about um getting folks invested in pvp
we're talking about you know just
attracting just the normal population to
pvp folks that generally enjoy pvp that
are maybe bored or you know the rewards
aren't there
it's i will say it's probably tougher of
a formula for them to uh design
activities limited time activities
design like an activity structure you
know across like a week
of planning or whatnot that are going
that that's going to get people invested
in playing pvp
that week purely to play pvp because
they enjoy it right and to get good
population numbers for that right
the like that's that's that's tough
that's tough um and it's something that
was easier it seemed like easier
seemed easier for them to do in d1
because we did have a variety of
different playlists and
it was generally population generally
was fairly sizable so it was solid it
was solid certainly we didn't have the
population issues i feel like that we
have right now with destiny 2.
now why is that the case
i'll just i'll just cut right to the
chase luke
loot you know like it it all comes back
to loot you're not gonna get
people to like people are gonna go
through some crazy struggles some like
they're gonna play [ __ ] that they don't
want to necessarily play or that they
don't enjoy as much what they don't even
know that they are going to enjoy a lot
of people come around to it because they
end up loving a playlist trials is a
great example of that a lot of people
got straight hooked on trials myself
included because the loot's great and
the loot ended up getting them over that
hump
where they got just good enough just
familiar enough with the playlist that
they could actually
enjoy it you know they could actually
enjoy it right um
so i i guess i guess
you know it all comes back to it it all
comes back to loot
this is a lunar shooter that's how you
get people you know invested that's how
you pique their interest is to give them
a nice
you know uh a nice consistent flow of
loot uh very loot that is um
not just consistent but uh like like you
could you can expect it at certain
points you know like it's it's not it's
not rng whether you get loot or new the
loot itself might the roles might be rng
but when you actually get that loot is
very structured for the most part
and so little little or what i've been
preaching
lock the loot behind reaching certain
ranking
levels right
and that's just they give it to you at
the end of the season based on the
highest rank you get to like there's
there's games that have been doing that
for a while and yeah even if you're not
even if you're not getting rewards every
match it's aspirational it's like you're
silver well the gold reward is a little
bit cooler it's a little bit better it's
got more flare better cosmetic or
whatever then that's a reason for you to
play a hundred matches potentially yeah
crazy and make and make that make that
the dope in game loot you know but then
you know and then and then have and then
have you know maybe like mats or like
you know some some other type of like
lower level loop
um you know i'm tired of matt's lower
level loot you know through that through
the actual progression through the
actual progression you know but it's
always going to come back to loot and a
little little nugget for folks you know
like because unfortunately i saw a few
things like iron banner is going to get
that rework you know for which queen it
is going to get that that rework and it
is going to be kind of dope okay it's
going to be kind of exclusive so i'm
just someone just let that sit right
there see some [ __ ] i probably shouldn't
have yeah let's let's just go ahead and
not break this man's uh yeah okay anyway
so no what actually you guys want a
really good idea but it made me think of
something like fiesta right now for halo
i love it with the with the event fiesta
it's like random loadouts right that you
guys get
but it's like we have all of if this
they want to get into the renewed focus
every sport the renewed focus of pvp
and shout out real quick uh
super chat i feel so detached
you mute it you made it you beat it you
did it sorry there you go touched it you
feel good forte with the 10 super chat i
feel so detached at the moment crucible
has been home for the last few years but
there's nothing for me to keep playing
pvp feels bare bones and that's saying a
lot when the franchise is seven years
old i mean it's true i mean that's kind
of one of those things but i was going
to say like we do enough holiday events
in this game
if they really want to bring pvp into a
balanced level
bring in like okay you got three weeks
of a holiday event make one of the
triumphs go play 50 matches of this
goofy mode that we created maybe it is
laser tag
for
that event and it's just one of those
things you can play it see how it is and
they could even do like a voting
afterwards hey is this a game mode you
guys would like to see in rotation hey
is there a shoddy snipers hey is there a
if they did an exotics gun game are you
kidding how much fun would that be oh
how like the
numbers
to go through you could like
you could have like gun game one and gun
game two you have so many exotics that
you could pick from like yeah and those
are all going to be static roles so you
could have your static rolls taken care
of that type of thing would be
and use your holiday events to like give
people as you said a reason to play them
maybe get over the hump of like hey do i
like it do i want to spend time in this
one
some of those triumph people like teddy
will at least spend time in that and get
an idea is this what they like as
opposed to baking the cookies for the
fourth year which i'm just like i'm not
looking forward to that
so and then it's funny to say that e
because they're actually going the
opposite way and destroying the
limited time uh
uh cursible events we didn't get our
doubles valentine's day yeah that's what
i'm saying
away from that
we need to bring those back like this is
part of the pvp piece like if
i was like you there's a piece of loot
you say loot loot loot and you even
mention mats as you go through and i'm
say i don't give two
yeah like we know i have no but it's
like you play enough you really really
don't need them
that's what i'm saying
let me tell you pvp players are poor
because we do not have access to the
mats that you do you rich i mean and
that and then then but give them to you
guys but it's like after a while that
runs out for anyone of course of course
is my point so it's like yeah
so there's nothing to spend your mats on
really yeah there's like you know i
every literally every class item that
drops from me right now is just pissing
me off whether it's blue whether it's
legendary i don't need a class item i
have four they don't change in stats
i've mastered one of each type i'm done
just shut that slot down stop dropping
it i don't need a class item until which
queen and then even then it's just
something until i infuse like class
items means nothing to me right i like
the new activity what they alluding to
with the way i mean i'm looking forward
to like you know seeing what that stuff
has but it's like it's gonna be a
foreign style piece of armor sure
functionally for what my character does
for stats or loadouts or anything else
will not change a thing that's the
problem like again armor and that's the
problem i keep seeing with all of this
stuff just reading between the lines no
major changes are coming to armor right
now and for me that's just like it's
it's sad because again you'll you can
still have four sets of armor and as
there is no sun setting infusion is
still there all i'm going to do is bump
up the numbers on my armor and my armor
will function the same they might give
me a few more mods to go after but every
armor drop doesn't matter to me
trial's armor looks cool
but it doesn't change the way i play
trials weapons technically can get you
know you could go after the adept you
can get some different like perks
different stats on those things like
they're a little different but armor
across like the whole right side of my
character
i just like and that's one of those
things where materials are mostly meant
to be spent over there because again
it only takes enhancement cores on the
left-hand side so all the high-level
materials after a while just don't do
much for me it's like and that's the
thing you go through and after i was
sitting there on double nightfall i
think rewards and i was playing through
just like i did like 20 runs and i ended
up getting like 50 cores 20 shards did
not get that many weapons in the double
loot weekend by the way wow
like 20 runs i think and i was i was
doing this on matchmade so i wasn't
doing the sunlight master so they will
drop higher there but i was seeing like
for a match made person to go in to see
how much they would get
i got like one to two prisms like every
time right
so like that's a good time to farm cores
were dropping two to five every strike
that we finished up
uh weapons were a couple but then even
when you start getting enough prisms
that's a point so it's like i know a
newer player will have much more to go
through yeah but there is a point to
where like as you guys have said the
loot in trials
doesn't mean much at all after even for
me i'm kind of getting to the point
where i like i have engram saved up i'm
like
i i don't know what i really need to go
for now because i've got like two or
three god roll reads like i'm good
shires i'm starting to get a couple i
feel good on igneous is probably one
where i can still get a good roll and
that's like the only one
but that's like yet like i'm getting to
the point where even me who's been solo
queuing trials and only mostly going
after reputation i am at the point where
i'm even running out of loot to go for
and if i'm at that point the people who
are like the rest of you guys that are
good at this and go to the lighthouse a
lot you ran out a while ago which is a
problem well two things two things i'll
make a note of you know like uh like
things are going to matter more as far
as math and things when we can actually
craft
you know i'm curious that nobody's very
curious
it's going to be new materials we got to
go earn but that's a different thing
yeah yeah so i mean you know the the the
materials even that we're getting right
now i assume you know even if they end
up transitioning some stuff over that's
gonna matter more when the crafting
comes up um that stuff is gonna be more
important for folks that both play the
game a lot and folks that that don't
play the game a lot it's number one uh
and then number two what was it uh i
think i was thinking that
um
like things yeah i think this is
actually this is actually what it is
like those mats and things they still
they still matter to me
at least because i'm one of those people
that plays the game a lot and am
invested in um
and just build crafting yeah you know
yeah like like like
all of my builds for pvp and if i have
time if i have time for pve if i'm if i
had like today i was running through
harbinger missions kind of just on the
fly no i didn't build crap for that but
trust me if i had more time if i if it
was a longer stream because it was a
short stream it was like three to four
hours if i had a longer stream you would
have seen me for the first hour like
going through a build craft pretty much
on like all three of my characters that
i had to run run on because i just want
everything to look and be crispy every
all the time you know and then we got to
get to the fashion side of it too
out there
takes care of that for you yeah i'm just
saying yeah so uh so we need to level
those up so you know for me the mats
still might still matter i play quite a
bit of pvp obviously the mats still
matter uh because every time i build a
new i'm i'm rocking you know i'm car
response right now you know i i made
sure that
you know i got max as much uh obviously
i gotta have my hundred recovery and
then from there i gotta make sure that
my grenades uh you know that grenade
industry is up all the time so eight
nine or ten on the grenades
so uh so that stuff you know that stuff
still uh still matters to me um and so
therefore that that again that leads me
back into uh that stuff is probably
going to matter a lot more once crafting
comes through um that's and yeah
probably fair probably about three
months yeah there's a point i guess of
diminishing returns of the value of
those because you are drawing down to
like fractions of improvement to a while
when you are doing builds like if you
depending on how many different builds
you want to go for i guess but there is
a point where i guess there's like
diminishing
to a point i guess somewhere no no
you're right yeah it is yeah but then
again with the with the ability with the
ability changes it might end up being
more impactful you know you might
actually hear me
i'm pretty curious about that too
because if i get my nade back a decent
amount sooner than you um especially
when we don't get them quite as often
then i'm not clutching that 1v2 i'm
touching that 1v3 because i had a nade
up and you didn't so it's kind of it
kind of actually moves back to year one
when a buddy of mine named fox uh kind
of put me on to the concept of yo a lot
of people don't spec into their grenade
they spec into their intellect and it's
just like look you know like how many
times you get your combination often in
a match but you get your super once
maybe twice max if it goes to goes
around make sure that you spec into your
grenade and so i've always seen benefit
in that just not in practice you know
like but also just conceptually i've
seen benefit in that and so um so yeah
you know and and oh this is the point i
was gonna make was that he made that
comment in year one when abilities came
through slower when you know abilities
more more impactful because you didn't
get them quite as often right um and
we're moving
obviously not back to year one which i
would never want but we're moving a
little bit more in that direction you
know in between you know kind of an
ability you know stasis maybe beyond
light and and a year one we're going a
little bit further back to year one so
um oh the last thing i was going to say
too is uh like loot refresh before i
forget like
yes like we need a loot refresh
especially in longer seasons but really
that's what's going to help out trials
the most yeah
population wise because
it just it just doesn't like even people
that love the game mode are still
probably going to get tired of it
there's very few people that are like me
and i don't care what the loot is i'm
gonna play every single weekend very few
people are like that even people that
love the playlist very few people are
like that you have to have a loot
refresh because the people that get all
of their loot
all that loot you know that that is to
offer within the first three four five
weekends and whatnot they're for the
most part not going to come back they're
not going to come back or if they come
back they're just going to play a few
games and that's going to be kind of
negligible when we talk about the wider
population and the benefits of having
that larger population for trials so
it's like that's got to be the most
important and one of the biggest
priorities i feel like for um any
anything the trials team does is to kind
of advocate for um a loot refresh at
least one mid-season to try to keep that
population high because we're most times
we're not going to have like it seems
most times we're not going to have as
long of a season right now so if we do
that loot refresh we should be in a much
better state um you know come this time
in a season and the last point i'll say
i agree with that and for comp i i would
love
the old pinnacle system to come back
because i felt like
with in relation to the ranking because
i felt like it it motivated me to get
that
you know recluse it motivated me you
know to get that ranking tied at
mountaintop i remember you in there you
know i'm saying like it motivated you to
get in there to exactly right yeah
that whole system needs no i mean we've
yeah beaten that horse yes but comp in
its comp and then freelance comp but
just comp in itself
that's the ranking system that needs
like the aspiration that needs a reason
to go for it and when you see people get
to onyx and halo you're like damn yeah
like
who like does it there's zero like
what's the point in going for 5 500
right now in comp like people would do
it to level up at the start of the
season just for the packages because
it's easier for you know skilled teams
but outside of that yeah
no there's nothing in there that's
worthwhile so yeah no i would say that
pretty much covers
trials of course it went a little long
but
what do you know
nothing normal here
next thing that's coming back kind of
heard rumors of this but it did actually
get confirmed moments of triumph is
coming back and it starts on tuesday so
we're gonna get about two and a half
almost three months of moments of
triumph to work on
checking a whole bunch of boxes teddy is
gonna have something to do for a while
so it's perfect timing really i almost
wish that some of the objectives and the
moments of triumphs required you to boot
up older bungee games
like you have to do it's moments of
bungee jump you have to go and like you
gotta go download marathon on steam yeah
you gotta go beat marathon you know that
sort of stuff that would be amazing go
go play halo reach you'll play reach
like that be great
you know you have to go play the entire
master chief collection very good
campaign
[Laughter]
yeah
but yeah that is launching so they're
gonna give you a little time to work on
that one for your mmi xxiii seal
triumphs will be there and of course
they got the black and gold always a
legit good color scheme
um the sparrow looks like seriously like
a bullet with kind of like the taperings
off the back
yeah i got to get the emblem angle front
door the ghost the emblem though yeah
it's like that with the sword it's very
royal it's very lordly i need this yeah
very sword kind of wrapped and it's like
little ribbon and you got the little
kind of wreaths on each side
now those yeah go take a picture at
those and
of course there's gonna be a t-shirt no
we're gonna have to get that one of
course but they got the strange coin
coming back from d1 dropping a strange
coin and somebody even asked if i don't
know if it was one of you guys oh it was
like before we started i think do you
think the strange coin is going to be
involved in the new i i think it's the
six player match we'll get into
the 30th anniversary here in a little
bit do you guys think it's going to be
involved in 9 30.
i i think there's no way it's a
coincidence they brought that back i
think i think it's probably going to be
the currency or the thing we're
collecting for this uh new six player
event like that'll be the whole you know
how there's always like a currency we're
grinding out yes always uh matchmade
events that's going to be it will be
strange coins that's why you think it's
going to stick around beyond the
matchmaking event because the
matchmaking event is probably going to
go away after the event right
i don't
well the third thing is i think there's
a content add-on so this is like if you
buy it for pc you still have to go buy
it on playstation so wherever you buy
the 30th that's where you're playing
specifically the dungeon i think the
sixth person is free but yeah that
content i think is going to be
perpetuating into witch queen it's going
to be dungeon should stay
and i guess the sixth player would
probably stay tuned i think that i think
the content will stay i think you'll be
able to hold on to the strange coins but
i don't think they'll be useful outside
of like this
yeah
that's just a shame but also understand
also understandable i mean you know
new uh
more currency can we get some glass
needles to reroll my exotics
uh but yeah so that actually starts
tuesday i'll be curious to see what the
deals with all of that uh before we get
into just kind of the 30th anniversary
chat which i did want to get with you
guys on kind of all the pictures and
stuff that kind of explored today armor
mods
real quick i do want to touch on those
the fact that armor mods are now going
to be
free
so it's actually something honestly i'm
pretty surprised that they're doing
because for somebody like physics over
here
if
it's free
and they said the third-party destiny
apps starting on december 7th can do
this theoretically people can now make
true
like all the way down to the mod
crafting loadouts yeah so potentially if
you could save a loadout with this armor
put these mods on it
like you could be flying into a trials
match and if you're like looking through
what they got you could switch it over
and maybe fast enough have a completely
different loadout and mods that match
just by clicking one button that's
actually got a lot of potential for
actually saving loadouts putting it in
game would be better but if like third
parties can get it set up that's
actually kind of intriguing
yeah i'm sure they're already going to
be there like day one right because
there's no transaction
but uh
i'm
i think it's time to get rid of glimmer
yeah i'm getting there
yeah it doesn't do anything
what yeah what's that what is it keeping
you from getting at this point what is
it even gating it stops you from buying
the what is it the repeatable bounties
because they're 3k
normal bounties are 250 which you never
feel that much but the ones the
repeatables which i guess can give you
bright dust are like three cases every
so often i'll go through if i'm doing a
lot of bounties i'm like why am i low on
glimmer because i but it's just buying
bounties but outside of that that's
literally why shouldn't you be able to
not to buy all the bounties i'm not
saying you shouldn't but that's one of
their probably like time gating
limitation things because if you don't
have the currencies to go over to spider
or rahul and which queen or whatever
it's going to be to exchange those and
just free up your glimmer that's a way
to like slow you down i guess on bright
dust so you don't get too much but
should it be an issue no i mean glimmer
doesn't serve much purpose on much at
this point yeah the only time i've ever
been disappointed in my glimmer stock is
when i'm trying to buy a trials card
and that's pretty weird but that's what
i realized
that's when i realized
yeah i got to go to the atm y'all be
back let me go hit spider right quick
and see what happens
in the tower
that's long overdue currency exchange
having to go to a different planet yeah
yeah
but it is kind of nice to see if you're
going to be able to apply armor 2.0 mods
perks
uh weapon perks you'll actually be able
to switch perks if you want to shaders
ornaments ghost projections which who
cares about some of that but the perks
the armor mods
those two being able to truly just set
up a loadout is yeah no actually it's
pretty exciting no that's beautiful
because you can do
like as far as when i like when i'm
building you know a new a new like
really really well min maxed optimized
build i open up them open up d2 armor
picker you know start in d2 armor picker
then i copy and paste it right over to
dim or whatnot and so to like the the
only thing that uh
the only thing that that is yeah the
only thing like i i love i would love to
always do the the fashion stuff you know
in destiny like it's beautiful like it's
just a beautiful interface and that sort
of thing but but yeah you know like as
far as like it's it's the other it's the
other side of the coin basically the
mods like i've already like switched all
my armor over like why not just put the
mods on there because the mods are are
part of the reason why i'm running the
build is because the mods are necessary
for me to get the stats you know that
the armor already provides a base you
know or that the armor you know like you
know what i'm saying oh you know what
i'm saying so um
so the mods are part of the stats you
know and the armor is the other half of
that so it just only makes sense that
you'd be able to apply both of those
things through dim and then we can do
the fashion and stuff like that inside
which is which is equally important by
the way equally that's right that's
right look at that that is the uh that
is the that'll look good while you're
breaking ankles right now they're gonna
be like oh man i can't stand anymore but
he looks good but he looks nice for real
when he's standing over me like that you
know he's look nice though chris yeah
that's a very fancy tea bag you've got
there sir
i alluded to it but i wasn't gonna say
it
over i was like oh
that is the day that he's indulging in
specific activities
hey hopefully that'll be less of a thing
coming up about four days five days a
lot of people are gonna have to start
using guns you know a lot of people got
that oh yeah yeah primary game yeah yeah
so the final piece we've got is the 30th
anniversary is around the corner and i
wanted to save this to kind of second to
last thing basically i've got one other
touch for you guys towards the end but
uh 30th anniversary so we started to see
some pictures dropped today if you look
up on steam for the 30th anniversary
pack you can see
one apparently there has a horse
it's a celestial horse it seems like but
apparently the nine have this horse
because
somebody had a picture of like the
drifter and then all the stuff that went
do it
it's butt stallion borderlands
i don't even know the raptors
yeah somebody somebody just put me on to
that today so mm-hmm okay uh but anyway
uh he's got a horse there is obviously
zur seems involved in what looks like
the sixth person i think
uh because he got six people standing
outside of this like glowing
thing and he also has like wheel of
fortune yeah with like whatever race
you're gonna be playing against or i
don't know if any of you guys watch dude
perfect the uh wheel unfortunate i think
is gonna be uh it's like wheel
unfortunately who's your enemy and it's
got cabal taken high vex and fallen you
got one of each so it's like all right
spin the wheel and i'm guessing see who
you're gonna fight against in this six
person dares of eternity mm-hmm
it's gonna be another one
what if i if i could derail the show yet
again
i feel like
i feel like i need to be the guy to say
um that that's not a horse it's a
unicorn which is different than an
alicorn and also different than a
pegasus okay okay all right there's
right there i guess
unicorn has a single horn what's the one
you said after unicorn okay so there's a
unicorn which has yeah that's a single
horn
there's an alicorn which has the wings
and the horn okay okay
no horn gestures
then there's a then there's a horse
yeah so what you're describing as a
dumpster okay and i want to i want to
pass on this knowledge that i definitely
didn't get from watching episodes of my
little pony friendship with magic
[Laughter]
that was hilarious by the way
he don't even know what to say
there you go east
so we have zur has a unicorn of course
zur has a unicorn
that's not he's a celestial unicorn with
a purple horn
why wouldn't he
anyway that place looks interesting
apparently got wheel of fortune of who
you're playing against
um but we also got the name for the
dungeon
it's the grasp of avarice
avarice is like a deception a lie
so if you look up everest that's no no
it may be a different avarice is extreme
greed for wealth or material gain oh
yeah sorry i'm thinking is this like the
story of
observe the trial observed like we were
learning back like grasp of everest
you're grasping for greed and we're
going into the loot cave
that's the dungeon so i mean they agree
they nailed
the name very very well um i thought
that was actually pretty funny
but like the grasp of everest we're
gonna go down it's like you know pirate
themed and all that stuff but like space
i don't know how they're gonna do it but
that is gonna be the dungeon that goes
live
dares of eternity goes live and um
which one are you guys going in first
what y'all doing what y'all doing
uh guys dungeon daddy it's gonna be yeah
he's not gonna do dungeon it's loot cave
themed it's got bungee loot in there
yeah let's do that yeah should i even
ask you e like of course
now the question is is if i run through
by myself first to try and figure it out
or if i probably bring in like a couple
people from my chat to run it the first
time so we get through it figure out the
mechanics and then i work on my solo
guide or whatever i got to figure out
content
plan for that day
um it's probably beat it first because
i'm guessing
it's going to kick off the gal horn
quest is when you beat the dungeon
that's my highest consciousness is where
they would put it that's that's fair
is somewhere in there or it's tied to it
or there's a connection but i'm guessing
that would probably be the best way to i
think get that going is probably do that
so
that brings me to another point of the
30th anniversary is
gallahorn yeah let's talk about it
how spicy of a fireball do you think is
how spicy of a meatball i should say do
you think this gal horn is going to be
uh because i was actually i can't i
think his tassie i was listening to one
of his just um
they are in an interesting position
because gallahorn has
their marketing their delayed season
expansion you have to pay for with one
gun
and a catalyst
so it can't suck
it can't come out like cryothesia it
can't be like hey
it can't come out like a turd
but it also they you know they're afraid
of breaking things so what do you guys
how do you where do you guys think on a
scale of like hotness one to ten where
is it gonna fall and two
what do you think the catalyst is going
to do it it's confirmed it's a catalyst
too
catalyst ornament and weapon are coming
with this package
yeah
the catalyst probably has to be probably
like increased tracking or something
right it's got it i mean it's god it's
going to be truth
it's going to be truth
i think it's going to be true
truth plus eyes of tomorrow it's just
going to be a better eyes of tomorrow
basically oh my god it's going to be
like truth
it comes
i'm thinking i'm thinking it's gotta
like come through at least at like a
seven or eight it's just got a history
it's got
you know it's got so much history in in
the community i don't think it's like
the last word it it can't come through
neutered it can't come through neutered
you know last word didn't come through
neutered i think it will oh do you think
it will it's all what's the theory i
think it will i don't know i don't think
we can make it as strong as it was so i
think that yeah i don't think yeah yeah
kind of
it'll be mad without the catalyst the
catalyst will make it
pretty good but
yeah that's what i think it'll be i
think i think it could be kind of nice
because it's it's heavy you don't have
to worry about it really breaking pvp
too much because it is heavy and heavy
doesn't come up like that you know
there's there's not a lot of heavy in
pvp right now right uh that being i
don't think they're worried about pvp at
all i think they're worried about pve
sure you know but laying on the
it could be one of the things to hold
everybody off until to which queen to
make us feel powerful in pve
you know
i don't understand i think there's more
i think there's more of a reason to make
it strong off the bat at least until
which queen um than to because you got
to get people to come back too you know
a lot of people have moved on to other
games because the season's been long um
i think there's more of a reason to make
it strong out the gate than there is to
to kind of neuter it out the gate to be
honest i would agree because i think
that
let's be real like the the the populist
house you know outside of the hardcore
is probably going down
you got to get people back right and
they've historically
have overtuned things have come in hot
you know what i'm saying like even
exotics they're the final fantasy 7
looking sword that is super
yeah
yeah that was busted oh i can't wait by
the way random random tangent i can't
wait for arbolus to be barrier
oh yeah yeah that's absolutely nice
because right now it's like it's i don't
want to use an auto rifle but if i can
go legendary legendary like legendary
linear and that and i can break shields
and barriers yeah yeah only looking
forward to the only thing i want to see
is
besides i'm with travel on this though
i think we reach final form when we get
that cat well that catalyst is going
it's going to be ignorant
that i'm actually looking forward to is
kind of when death what is it death
bringer death bringer
had his moment was when you threw that
warhead um mod on top of it with the
rocket launcher the extra 20 or 30
percent yeah that's when it could get
stupid
like so i could just see like six people
in a raid clips of eighth yard getting
melted in seconds gally's back see they
want that
get the hype give him the marketing get
people to come back exactly
you know what we realized like our vex
we realized
the cayenne pepper uh was a little high
we we pulled back a little bit on that
spice yep
i don't know man what you think what do
you think
i think they
thought that that's what they were doing
when they made stasis
i thought they were doing that thing
where they go oh we'll make it a little
overpowered on purpose and it'll be like
tongue-in-cheek it'll be fun and people
will have fun with it and then we'll
nerf it and i think them trying that
with stasis and then it backfired
entirely because everybody knew that
immediately
they knew that was coming in hot like
they even knew they
they of course knew it was coming in hot
but that's my point is that i think
they're not going to make things
knowingly come in hot as black yeah but
that's that because they saw how that
bad that could go wrong you know yeah
yeah but that but but
fundamentally yeah yeah but gal is not
going to fundamentally break pvp because
the thing is people weren't complaining
about stasis in pve you know like i said
it wouldn't have been if anything titans
still suck at it but that's fine yeah so
i mean you know like like to make the
comparison you're warlock stasis and pvp
you can't shake your head shake my hand
but god forbid the titans don't have
everything in every class he got it he's
got to let us know we think that we do
we've always been the class that you
know we get out of here
anyway oh we're doing it
wait that's what we do
no we don't like it
the same thing we did last time man
but i'm saying like and pvp at least
like warlocks have have have been kind
of like the
you know a lot of times they get some
pretty extreme nerfs warlocks i feel
like in pvp and uh
yeah it's just
there's an inconsistent presence of
had some op stuff too they they have but
they have one
but it's really inconsistent it's really
inconsistent till top dawn came around
for example you know warlocks weren't
truly truly on the map in pvp
consistently you know still till top don
came around like it was kind of niche
you know to get warlocks over like a
titan or a hunter
so you know like if if there's any if
there's any uh to try to be as objective
as possible if there's any class you
know that
needed a slap you know they needed love
it was it was warm
slap you want to know how strong
warlocks were
just look how hard they nerfed
um
what's the nova warp one
oh yeah
that was so strong they nerfed it into
the ground they were so scared of that
thing it's been trying to come back to
life yeah and again yeah they took it
too far but that's how scared they were
it really does seem like i've noticed
the pattern with warlocks is when
warlocks do end up getting that op
status they come in like hard like
they're [ __ ] strong
the season of the hammers the the mask
of i could see you through the wall when
i tracked you don't get me started on
how long you can freeze me
i think i agree with you i just think
that you guys are allowed to misbehave
longer when weak finally gets something
the bit never comes down
quick i think the difference is
outside of it
outside of when hammers hammers started
opening yeah
it's true yeah when you heard that og
claim everybody ran and then it got that
was the biggest shutdown for titans now
i will say that for sure but i will also
say like the warlocks have had bigger
peaks with some of theirs i'll agree
with that the titans
their peaks are lower but their
weaknesses are also lower they're sort
of just like the moderates of the world
that's why i say titans don't complain
we just deal with what's going on except
we let the warlocks cry we let the
hunters especially
hunters be crying you let them ego
everybody you let the hunters do
whatever they're gonna do you all agree
there yeah
i do feel just complaining the most
everybody knows that your guyses are the
most made for pvp yeah like you get it
you have the jump that's best if you
actually listen to
if you listen to kevin diana
yeah the one with the five like you know
fallout cool guy mark all them um
kevin yana says he's like we're okay
with the class being better in pvp
they basically like they know that
hunters in are better in pvp and that
dodge so that they've finally they're
gonna get a little little clip in the
hamstring there but like dodge is still
one of them firing range thank you i'm
just blanking um
they flat set it like there you go it's
like there's a reason because it is that
dodge is the most functional thing in
pvp you can put up a wall that's slow
yes the well is has some benefits now
especially with your little turrets and
stuff but that dodge can change the
course of any gun fat faster than
anything else break tracking on tracking
things towards it now they finally
nerfed that you know because that was
the thing i remember throwing an axe in
bolt and my boat gets confused because
all that you gotta do is just dip and be
like yeah please see ya yeah that thing
ain't catching nothing
yeah so but i will say on the other side
pve is a hunter when i've run it which i
haven't run in a while i've been on my
titan for a while but pve is a hunter on
the other side i agree i tend to feel
squishy either so it but granted the
invisibility has been a pretty
beneficial thing for groups at least so
yeah they have their ups and downs on
sides for sure
warlocks are like the best for pve yeah
exactly to be the best for pvp and again
titans are the moderators
agree good at both yep yeah
we have our ups we have our towns
yeah so the last thing i wanted to ask
you guys as we get close to two hours
here and i was actually talking with
chat the other night and thinking about
this one as well
we're on this 10-year saga i know this
is going to take us off a little tangent
but i kind of want to see what you guys
think
we're on this like 10-year saga we know
we've got
witch queen february 2022
light fall hopefully 2023 final shape
2024.
how do you guys expect us because they
say destiny 2 will continue
and i was just a random question of how
you guys think the franchise will
continue
if destiny 2 will continue
will they bring back cytoscenic by that
time is it going to be a clean sweep and
this is like you're making a new
character but destiny 2 still around are
the planets still going to be here are
we going outside of the solar like
if destiny 2 will continue as they said
or do does bungie not even know right
now which is kind of what we may have
come up with how do you think
and this is the other pieces like you go
so the big pieces of the story are the
expansions
generally our seasons are telling a lot
more stories but how do you take it to
where witch queen new planet that one
and we're gonna have season 17 18 19
stuff that takes us through to
lightfall then we're gonna have the big
expansion the content all that stuff
probably a new destination season season
season then you get the final shape
expansion
are there gonna be seasons attached to
that does the final season which is like
i think i did the math season 27
is that final season
going to just like wither off to the end
is that going to carry us over so it's
just a random question i want to ask you
guys
where you think the franchise is going
to end like season 20 or 24 for
final shape season 27
where do you guys think this whole
10 years is gonna wrap and how will it
how will it go forward because i was
honestly i got to the point because if
the final expansion still has seasons i
have to wonder a lot of what's the point
i have yeah please for the love of
please for the love of god give us vault
space by then yes i agree with that
no i've got thoughts
yeah my thoughts are that um a i don't i
i tend to agree that i don't think
bungie knows the answer yet um i think
they probably told us a little bit after
internally they had kind of decided that
this was the direction they wanted to go
as a company that the teams were still
interested in working on destiny i think
uh
they probably still don't know exactly
what that looks like but i'm of the
opinion that the end of darkness and
light saga the final shape is going to
have seasons afterward because i think
that the transition from um
destiny 2 darkness and light saga to
non-darkness and light saga is a softer
reboot than we might be thinking right
we're we're thinking of it as like one
game ending in a new game beginning and
i think they're just thinking of
narratively kind of resetting and having
kind of like a reboot of like the things
we talk about less about darkness and
light and less about uh you know the
struggle against this ancient evil and
more about like what's next like what
what how could we
take this uh this saga to a different
era and talk about different stuff i
think that's how they're thinking about
it so i think there will probably
probably be seasons
after the final shape that sort of serve
as a connective tissue between the end
of the darkness and light saga and
whatever this new story is just like
the seasons this
year have sort of transitioned us from
beyond light to
uh sabathun and witch queen i think
it'll it'll probably be very similar
that said i think there will probably be
some things that they need to overhaul
that are bigger and it's more of a
question of if those fit into the
timeline because we've talked about a
lot the need for a new engine or for
them to revise the engine or do
something there and so my question is
if they're still going to be destiny 2
is there going to be an engine update
that happens around that same time or
can they even afford to wait that long
that's a even bigger question right can
they can they wait that long or is that
something they're going to have to do
even sooner and so
um i think story-wise it's more of a
philosophical we're ending one story and
we're beginning another we're not ending
one game and beginning another but there
probably are other things
on a game level like the engine that
that are represent in my opinion bigger
changes that they're probably going to
have to address maybe even before then
if they managed to hold out until 2024
with the same engine i would be really
impressed because i have no idea what i
agree gaming landscape looks like in
2024 but i'm guessing we have an xbox
series x2 and a ps5 pro and i'm guessing
things look a lot different than they do
now and i don't see the engine if if it
makes it that far it will be it will be
chugging
like you know it'll be on it's it's
death bed by the time it gets there so
we'll see though i mean halo is
replacing its engine for the very first
time with halo infinite it's been 20
years same engine blaming this this is
the first game that has a new engine is
this the space what is it we'll see what
is this the blam engine blam and now
it's slip space now it's their space
though uh tony i'm curious man what you
thinking long term oh man uh shh
man it's not something i'm off guard
here caught him off guard all right
sweetie no no no you didn't do this
i guess i guess a little bit a little
bit it's not something that i've thought
about
a lot uh i will say within the one one
thing that immediately came to mind was
uh their hiring decisions i mean
everybody has probably been following
the fact that they have
um
they've hired some uh narrative like
movie people right
like so they could actually it seems
like destiny and bungie's going to go in
the direction of producing some media um
for movies television et cetera et
cetera give me the destiny arcane carry
over from netflix yeah that'd be dope
that'd be dope
that being the case uh since you know
that whole media market is kind of very
very
very rebooty right for lack of better
words i think we we would expect more of
a reboot um than than a continuation i
think we would expect some fresh
directions especially since uh you know
we kind of got a fairly straightforward
carry on from destiny 1 and destiny 2 as
far as the narrative focus right um
uh you know light still remained uh now
we have light and dark it was it was
basically you know destiny 2 is is just
destiny 1 i mean especially considering
the fact that we didn't really even get
that many like engine upgrades and and
things along that side until
what was it like last year i guess with
beyond light right right so um
so yeah you know i would expect more of
a reboot i guess is what i'm saying is
what i'm thinking um taking us in a much
more fresh direction than we got with
the destiny 1 destiny 2 transition what
is it going to look like that final year
i would always expect that final year
that final six months to be kind of like
a rise of iron type of situation where
they aren't able to really
um
uh hold down
like heavy resources
um heavy resources you know coming into
destiny 3 where if this if again if it's
destiny 3 it's like yeah it's got to be
on it kind of like you know it's got to
be on a new one
it's got to be a new engine and that's
probably going to take quite a bit quite
a bit of their resources i mean they're
expanding right but still it's going to
take quite a bit of the resources so if
i was going to guess we i would i would
definitely look for a very very chill
stagnant
live team only type of like hands-on
thing going for like last like six
months uh nine months and uh i would
expect more of a reboot than anything
else uh going into destiny 3. those are
those are kind of my thoughts based on
you know what i've seen in the context
surrounding what what bungie's going
through specifically as a company and
their hires and that sort of thing
completely agree with both of you i
think you guys are both on fire i think
that's exactly what's going to happen
you know them
cementing destiny 2 will continue to me
show that the road map is way longer
um i do think
the the final i'm not getting caught up
with the final shape stuff e because i'm
with trav i think that is just narrative
beat i think that the story will
continue seasons will continue and i
think it's all contingent
what happened
the crossfade to the next like to the
next like one blends down over the other
one of these just a narrative thing all
ends are beginnings yes the stranger
told us they're just gonna break down
some new narrative beats and it'll
probably be interesting and cool but
what i agree with tony is the fact that
if you look at i just we just did a
defining duke about this and i brought
up destiny and it becomes it comes down
to the interest of the games industry
and the movie industry right now kind of
having this this marriage this
relationship where they could both be
lucrative and i think they're seeing it
right now because you're seeing things
like the witcher you're seeing when it's
actually done right and the attention is
paid to the law and then we've got the
evidence right before us i mean we've
seen luke smith and mark noseworthy now
be elevated to the purveyors of the
destiny universe for music tv film or
whatever so they're looking to expand
this thing to the outstretchers and
really take bungie to the next level and
i think that's still part of the plan
now ultimately i know this is you ain't
gonna like this part because i know how
you feel about the engine
i think ultimately what happens is
that we're still stuck with d2 they'll
iterate slowly right they'll do iterate
on engines on the back end stuff that's
why i think destiny content vault exists
because there's that size limitation
reboot it out bring it through but
that's going to keep d2 longer in the
tooth but what i do agree with travis
said eloquently is that
at some point
the
base playstation the everyone will be at
the next generation and and maybe by the
end of final shape and stuff and then
they can financially as a corporation
say okay we have the engagement now
everyone's on the next-gen platforms
they're on the high-end pcs the base
we've pushed the limit there and then
they can kind of justify but right now
with the chip shortages the adoption
rate being very hard on next generation
consoles they can't justify making a d3
right now and i think ultimately that's
that's kind of where we are right now so
it's gonna be a while it's gonna be a
while i think um
my prediction that guy is gonna be
sunsetting i think we'll return
and so forth i still gonna start
standing on it i think sunsetting will
return at some point they'll ease it in
in some way some fashion you know
because of our power creep i think that
because that really technically hasn't
gotten eliminated you know um and i
think that um
yeah we're just gonna get
more story we're gonna get more story
more seasons that kind of bit and they
will keep content vaulting and adding
new stuff to ease chagrin
[Laughter]
sorry i know i know how you feel about
that i want the engine too i want
dedicated you know how it is i want
dedicated servers i want i want all that
stuff it's just
yeah i just don't think that's to happen
for d3 i honestly just don't
know i think they will they think there
will be a g3
i do i think that i don't know if
they'll be a d3 that's a good question
they might just stick with whatever
their new ip is and then just let that
run after destiny finishes or they might
start up a new ip in order to uh you
know supplement whatever their new ip is
and where that new ip
leaves
you know what's what's lacking you know
in comparison to destiny the destiny
franchise but what i do not see
happening honestly in destiny 2's you
know uh like lifetime um is i don't see
it going to a brand new engine and i
don't see dedicated servers i just
definitely don't they will they've got
smart people over there they're working
on it they continue to you know be on
top of it as far as um you know the best
that they can
uh what i do see is they just continuing
to be creative about how
they uh they keep this series alive
it's all about the tigers the cheetahs
fighter two yeah tigers and [ __ ] back
there throw back
e
uh i mean i'm somewhere between all of
you guys of i think
the biggest thing is i think it makes
sense that it is gonna be some type of
like blend
i think it's just gonna feel weird it's
like
what i wonder about the whole blend like
if light falls the end of the light and
dark saga
if they say destiny 2 will continue
will my
as you said sun setting feels like it
kind of has to come back or is that when
they do kind of uh do they do a reset at
that point with like do they wipe your
vault do is there
is there a point where they do actually
clean you out oh like like a narrative
beat for it
yeah they blow up the tower again for
some reason or whatever like that's
because i mean at some point we are if
power creep sunsetting either if yeah
power creep sunsetting i mean how many
horizontal moves and perks can we get
like i know tony you like making builds
but it's like there's gonna be a point
where they run into a a limit or a wall
of like okay we can only reiterate this
stuff so many times so i wonder
if they want to fix some of the
narrative problems with destiny 2.
one of the outs they have is killing our
character at the end of darkness and
life that solves a few problems it means
that the next uh game can be more
focused on narrative and actually give
us voice actors and not be so attached
to this kind of semi-sound protagonist
that we've known for all these years it
can also clear out our vault space and
give like a fresh restart to the loot
that we have and all that stuff
there's also changes to the world stuff
like that but there could be a reason
that our our uh guardians aren't around
anymore or possibly guardians entirely
aren't around anymore we really don't
know what the final show what are we
yeah we don't we don't know what the
world is going to look like at the end
of the darkness and light saga so i
think there's a lot of opportunity to
like
be out with old and with the new
narratively
it also it also kind of fits with how
long i think the game can probably exist
without needing a refresh i mean you
gotta admit you got you gotta assume
that by the final shape it's going to be
seven years
it's going to be very close to where it
was at with um
with the season of the drifter you know
when we were all
at max power creep levels before they
finally implemented sunsetting so it's
gonna be pretty yeah yeah so yeah it's
like that's like that's again like
questions i'm like i don't know what
their plan is for that type of stuff but
as you guys say there's there's the
movies there's the tv shows it's like
and there's amazing stories they can
tell but yeah it's like there is the
matter the other ip whether it's like a
cartoon animated hero shooter or who
knows whatever this thing's a little
more
like light-hearted um but again they
said like destiny 2 will continue in
some way and as you guys have said
is it just the patents where it's like
they don't change the destiny 2 name
that's one of the reasons it's like i've
heard what is it dota 2 doesn't change
it's because they have that name so many
places they don't want to do a dota 3.
they just do whatever they do with that
same principle for like destiny 2 is
like it is destiny 2 because that is
just what it is called everywhere the
like websites and everything else is
just like stuck and that's fine but
how does it come back what do we go
forward it was just one of those things
i thought about and i'm like i kind of
wonder how whatever the transition is
how we go forward as you said are we in
that grave at the end of the quarters of
time that we found remember that and is
that the way i forgot about it
to where we actually wrap up
our character's story as a guardian and
then we're
who knows something else at that point
forgot about that yeah it's just one of
those random things like i got to
talking myself in a circle and i was
like i don't know how they end this
thing
but also go forward it's just weird so
random thought i had started to take us
down that tangent it was great it was a
great tension i haven't thought about it
too much so that's it was great
well now i've planted that weird seed of
inception in your head good luck
but now we all have a reason to live
until 2024
we have to know we got to know
[Music]
how it all comes together so
well uh
anybody else have anything else i think
at this point we've probably uh hash out
a pretty good episode just shout out to
the weapon ornament changing
that's just like pull out your cell
phone be like oh it's your micro
transaction in your mobile game now
that's this is this ava lavonte is now
on your weapons i've been wanting the
ornament i want
on demand for a long time
so this would be a shock shout out to
shout out to our longest running segment
we didn't get to do it even though we
had a pvp main character i don't know i
mean you could ask him
real quick yeah yeah come on let's get
it all right
let's do it let's do it all right um
tony my friend we have a longest running
segment here on the show it's been it's
been around for well who can even
remember
and probably probably got a pretty fine
point when you joined the series but
that's what
the segment is called let's help ibontis
and it is a segment i like to do when we
bring pvp mains on
to help ibontus get out of the depths
of
serfdom that he exists
as in the world in the world of
competitive destiny um so the way the
way i like to do this is i ask our pvp
main guest what is
one tip
that you think
every pvp aspirant player should know
that might make them a better player
um you know we've heard the two-second
rule we've heard um the
what is it the one-sixth rule where you
should always be 60-40 like yeah that
was yeah 64-year rule whatever that one
is that was one um are there any tips
that you have that are just sort of like
a good rule of thumb to help ebontis's
thumbs be
be a little less clump
[Laughter]
almost almost there you almost got it
man that's that's a that's a tough one
that's a tough one i'm sure
i'm sure i've got something that's kind
of like an over i'm trying not to be
vague with my play with intention one um
i don't think that's specific enough
um
but that's that's a good that's a good
one explain it that's a good overarching
one i mean what i mean by that folks if
if people don't understand exactly what
i'm saying about that is play with
intention don't just drop when you drop
into a game and you're trying to play
for improvement
um
like you you are
playing with the intention for
improvement therefore you are
um you are being mindful of how you are
playing
um and then once you finish playing
whether it be that engagement once
whether that whether you're uh whether
you're finished playing that game um you
are going back in your mind
and you are trying to figure out okay
well i should have done this right here
oh i did a great job with that you know
it's it's kind of
it's kind of like being mindful in the
moment i mean whether you whether you uh
whether you
record your gameplay to watch later you
know this is kind of like a microcosm of
that like like in the moment being
mindful of how you were playing how you
were engaging and then switching things
up you know almost immediately in order
to kind of rectify or to double down on
something that you thought you did
really well um in engagement so that's
that's sure that's that's kind of like
we could we could talk about that for
like a while but if i was gonna give
something a little bit more specific
um and kind of kind of in the same vein
as that
if you if you're if you're playing
trials game for example or even sixes
don't worry about this person over here
this worry about that engagement in
front of you if you watch me play
if you watch me play you will see me
laser focused on one person in front of
me that's it that engagement even though
there is somebody right next to them
over here and there's somebody right
behind me if i don't give
ultimate one 100 focus on the person
that i'm engaging with that i'm shooting
with
shooting at that that time then i don't
three tap that person i don't three tap
that person with my hand cannon and when
i don't three tap that person with my
hand cannon and i get like a body shot
it takes me longer to kill that person
to eliminate that person so i can't
shift my focus then off to the next
person you know or i can't recover you
know or whatever else or i get team shot
because that person stayed alive for
just that split second longer and now it
gives this person over here that time to
like slide in
so if there was like a tip it's just
like don't worry about dying to the
second person don't worry about that
second engagement that third engagement
that's going to happen in the future
worry about that one engagement
in front of you give that person your
full attention now there are exceptions
like target switching and things like
that we can get into that later but that
that's got to be the thing i see people
get distracted with the most whenever
i'm running my community customs is just
like they're so worried about this or
that over there
which are important things to worry
about they may end up being a threat
you know but you can't control
everything control that one thing in
front of you make sure you get a good
good engagement right there get the
optimal ttk and then you can make a
decision
then you can make
then you can make a plan for the second
person then you can make a plan for the
third person i go i'm a very serial
player for the most part what i mean by
cereal and not a serial killer yeah
one
saying is like if folks are familiar
with the concept of like a cereal a
cereal pattern versus like a you know a
parallel somebody's somebody's like
grape nuts versus cinnamon toast crunch
this is what you're dealing with on the
show this is more iq level you're
talking about like the uh actual
definition of cereal and we're here with
our weedies
this is our level yeah but i go i go
from one one engagement and give my full
my full focus my zero to 100 is
everything that i do and so i give my
full attention to cognito and then once
cognito's down then i give the next
person the attention then i give the
next person whether that ends up working
out or not that's how i still play it
because
yeah yeah if you try to focus on too
many things too many players at the same
time then you're going to end up
splitting your attention and you're not
going to give you know you're not going
to give yourself the best you're
fighting 1v3 fight 1v1s fight 1v1 and
that's why you see people run around the
map in like a 1v3 situation you see them
running around the map trying to isolate
1v1s 1v1s and even when i'm facing three
people i use cover to try to isolate
1v1s if two people are like right here
but i've got one person right here i
just make sure i angle myself behind
cover so i'm i'm blocked from these two
people and i can take out this one
person then once this person's down
angle myself a little bit more
take out this next person keep this
person over here so that i'm behind
cover from that person take that person
out and then angle again i've done it
like i do it all the time and so
um that's that's the play focus on that
one engagement in front of you and don't
worry about whether you die to like the
second or third person you're just in a
better situation when you can give a
hundred percent of your attention and
100 of your shot 100 of your skills to
that one person in front of you and then
keep it moving from there that's right
then we need to stay there we go what's
that one beat them tea bag and serial
remote no okay all right
uh no i did want to actually say like i
worked on
i knocked out i haven't done a lot of
catalyst in a while
i think i finished up like 15 catalysts
or some stupid amount that i did i did i
finished i got sleeper to drop
my sleeper catalyst had not dropped and
i've done more nightfalls than i know so
that finally dropped i'm like okay so
where am i gonna go
away
went into the throw away and
i started working on one i was like well
i need to shoot other stuff so i'm like
okay what other things i started just
pulling out i had one i'd start
switching weapons between what ammo
sitting on the ground and going back and
forth and then i had to take cryostesia
into pvp
that one hurt
but i will say
i was like
hum where i read and so i remember
somebody's saying it's like i had better
luck at doing this in rumble
so i took it into rumble
and i tried to pair it with something
reasonable on the other side for a
little bit more range or something
but i was like i will say like the
little bit of time that i spent in
rumble and i haven't played rumble in
forever
it is a very good way as tony said yes
work on your one-on-ones yes have a and
you because all of those are typically
gonna be that now granted as you said
you can focus on this one and get shot
and finished up over here but if you
beat that one-on-one that's what almost
all of those are going to be so if you
want to practice your one-on-one skill
whether it's range understanding a map
or seeing those pieces like if you beat
them in the gun fight then you can start
applying that in other places and i was
just gonna say it's like don't totally
sleep on rumble you may get stomped and
i'll get stopped plenty because there's
like i'll be like oh you're tied for
third at nine and the other guy's at
like 20 i was like well
i got some but it's like it is a way for
you to practice that one-on-one gun
fighting so it was a way that i was like
i hadn't done that in a while i did
finish it but yeah yeah that was
probably the hardest catalyst i did it's
a good test for me too when it's um
sometimes i like to see the the
efficiency of specific weapons that i
sometimes fall in love with but how
really how good are they in certain
one-on-one uh engagements and i like to
test out romo is good for that and like
you said like tony said just the uh
focusing that razor focus on engagement
really it really helps you refine your
skills so yeah i agree with that
yeah
well as we wrap this thing up the floor
is gonna be yours sir physics tony i
called you both at some point so
uh where can people find you what do you
like doing where can they jump into your
customs and get you to review that what
do you what do you got going on the
floor is yours
let them know where they can find you
when and how hey
thank you i appreciate it uh thank you
so much again for always being
so kind and bringing me out here and we
just always have such great
conversations and i love hearing you
guys perspectives all you guys are such
smart smart people knowledgeable people
and i always learn something you know uh
and so yeah i just i just coming from
the guy with the masters
by the way
look look degrees and everything
and everything you know
oh boy so i truly appreciate it thank
you thank you so much um uh as far as
where you can find me you can find me
ill physics on twitter you can find me
on physics on twitch those are my two
biggest platforms uh in discord is
discord dot g uh dot gg slash ill
physics jump in the discord is a public
discord we got a great community over a
thousand strong in there just awesome
beautiful people um
i uh
i hinge my community very heavily on
being inclusive being uh thoughtful as
well so i mean you know a lot of what i
do
with regards to streaming and on twitter
is kind of cultivating a community um
that is again thoughtful inclusive that
you know people think critically people
think about other people's feelings and
don't just say some weird [ __ ] um
and uh and all of us to hopefully you
know like grow whether it be you know in
destiny or whether it be just in our
lives um in our friendships um in our
relationships so um so that's the goal
um you could find me
like you could go to my link tree that
is on my twitter um and you can find the
rest of uh rest of my links or whatnot
but it's ill physics on the big ones
twitter um twitch
um
discord youtube and then you know it's
elast physics on a couple of different
things but just go to my twitter you can
just go to the link tree and figure out
everything else uh as far as my content
what you uh can expect is a lot of pvp
and destiny i am a pvp main in destiny
but i love pve i love gambit you'll see
me take breaks thursday is usually the
day like today on stream we did
harbinger runs harbinger help
um and i love pve i love like i said
gambit um i just do more of pvp just to
you know keep my skills sharp and i
enjoy the activity itself the mode
itself uh more than the other two um but
gotta stay start gotta stay sharp gotta
drop some people right so yes sir um
otherwise we do get into some variety
every once in a while most definitely
usually if it's leaning more towards the
weekend the phasmaphobia phobias you
know the jedi fall into orders
[Music]
are you are you going to be playing
are you going to play elden ring
i'm going to try elder ring for sure
it's not the type of game i usually play
that's what you said fall in order which
is like
it's like
not babies first like souls but it has
more of that intentional combat to it
that's true no you're absolutely you're
absolutely true yeah it's absolutely
right you know um it's it's a it's a it
looks absolutely amazing and that's
really the thing that's going that's
going to get me on most like hades for
example like it's not the type of game i
would normally play either but that is a
game that is 100 on my list 100 on my
list you better find some time to like
dedicate to that if you've got like down
time in the destiny season hades
is one of those games like i haven't
done that many roguelikes and i think i
played at the start of the season new
rad might be able to correct me i played
i couldn't put it down
every run you want to keep going and
they do so many things the progression
and the story
make like it to be one of the best
roguelikes i've ever played
yes
i've heard i've heard amazing things i
read the review i think on ign as soon
as they came out um so so yeah i'm i'm
excited to try it i don't get the
opportunity um to uh to try new games
often but it is definitely on my list
and so that's my point with with eldon
ring is it just looks beautiful i don't
care if it looks amazing um
you know it has a great trailer it seems
like it has some solid lore to it like a
narrative is always going to be
something that hooks me that's the same
thing like i love a great narrative in a
movie or in a series great character
development then that's something that's
generally going to get me to try it
these days so um so yeah um every once
in a while you get some variety as far
as uh you know kind of community
oriented uh content that i do in destiny
uh the main one that folks know me for
is uh something that we do on sundays at
2 p.m eastern called community customs
and that's where i kind of give back to
my community and the water community at
large and like i never want to gatekeep
really anything knowledge whether it be
from streaming or from video editing and
things like that somebody asked me i'm
gonna try to give that experience in a
very detailed way so that you know folks
can up their game as well i want to be
able to to kind of i like the concept of
all ships rising together you know not
just not just me you know i see more
benefit in that community wise
um community customs is a great way for
me to do that and for me to share that
seven you know year six seven years of
high level pvp experience um and it's
where i don't play the customs myself i
spectate through the eyes via either um
be either like a twitch stream or a
youtube stream like everybody streams or
to the discord which is more uh more
likely everybody streams individually
one by one they play customs in a trials
format and i just i i spectate and i
listen through and then i have uh my pad
and i write down for that individual you
know constructive feedback constructive
criticism with regards to their gameplay
and what what i see and what can help
them but also
at the very least equally what's
important as well is to double down um
on things that they do great you know
the positives that i like whether it be
great plays great uh great reaction
great thinking great shooting or whether
it be something super creative that i
just haven't seen before that i want to
make sure that i i
they they double down on because i want
folks to have fun first and foremost it
can't just be that like people get burnt
out if it's all just about competitive
play competitive play just trying to get
better that's the focus no in the end
the focus has to be falling back on hey
i'm having a good time i'm having fun
you know i'm i'm using a build that i
want to use even though it may not be a
meta build even though it may not be a
competitive build it's something that i
really enjoy and i want to make sure
that i will enforce that this is
something that i reinforce you know um
and uh and that uh yeah folks see
benefit in so anyway um that's that's
community customs uh it is open to
everyone all you have to do is jump into
the discord like i said discord dot gg
slash ill physics and uh hop into the
general chat and just at me you know at
tony or you know whatever my role is up
there still physics or tony of both of
those accounts um are mine and just ask
me for the padawan roll which is after
obviously star wars okay um and uh once
you you just got brownies
right there
yeah right there
every once in a while yeah every once in
a while i have a guest mentor that comes
through who's who's generally better
than at the game that i am and they're
actually they actually have the jedi
role so
somebody a trap part of this team this
is steve speaker this star wars soul
right now
so every wednesday or thursday i ping
the padawan roll in the discord ask who
wants to participate in community
customs for sunday i pick six
everybody's there at 2 p.m eastern and
then i stream it and then we just go
through each of the six and uh what's
your role
jedi master what's the uh well i'm i
well you know like i'm still a jedi i
don't actually have it i'm just i'm just
physics i'm just physics you know and
i'm the professor
everything falls off
you need to be on the jedi council or
something you need to be part of that we
need a giant council i want there to be
a hierarchy here true enough in the end
the discord and you know my theme
follows ill physics and physics and
science you know more than anything else
so my role is the professor role right
um you know the the the jedi role the
star wars that incorporation is kind of
like a a subset of that so okay okay
well you could be the jedi if you're
others do the others come in as jedi
master just jedi
they come in as jedi oh is there a jedi
master travis is that a thing
versus a jedi the thing is a lot of the
people that are jedi are better than me
at the game so that's why you could be
jedi they could be jedi master and then
you the jedis are learning from the
padawan that's
that's actually totally fine ill physics
because lots of jedi knights are better
than jedi masters it's it's really just
a bureaucracy they're gonna really get
into it it's all about the politics
of jedi masters it's really political
and then we want to talk about the jedi
council getting on that is like
basically like you're a politician at
that point
here we go got you got you got you
understood understood
yeah we almost made it through almost
almost yeah almost made it through
without me talking about fast and
furious stuff
somehow i was talking about my little
pony i didn't yeah
we got a little cool family okay okay we
got it all we gotta do yeah well travis
that's where you can find me that's
that's the content no doubt brother
travis do you have a
happier review in your future i hope
i think so yeah i'm reviewing a game
that i can't remember the name of
because i just got assigned it like 20
minutes before this podcast but yeah i'm
reviewing a new game uh on steam uh that
probably will be done it'll be after
next week because i blacked out next
week to play halo infinite campaign i
already told him not doing it i'll give
me some time off uh this weekend though
i'm i'm previewing a game um that i
can't talk about i just remembered uh
i'm sorry stay tuned reviewing a game
that will be live on wednesday it is an
ign exclusive a game that's uh still in
alpha uh no gameplay has been shown of
it yet so we're breaking the um the
gameplay
debut there
which would be cool and then i've got a
review coming up down down the road
after i'm done playing halo infinite
until my eyes bleed and then uh you can
watch me uh every sunday i do a show
called bitcast where we talk about
general video game news a guy named ains
is there he's an industry vet and then
we also have a man who answers the
question what would a trailer park look
like if it were a person um so yeah it's
quite a good
one
yeah so yeah you can watch me there
watch my articles uh reviews and
previews on ign.com and follow me on
twitter at thai guy travis if you care
about the stupid things i talk about on
that
twitter
thing uh how about you cog where can
people find you yeah which low-key
podcast are you on sir nothing major
right before we do that man salute ill
physics back into it at the campfire man
this is always a pleasure when he comes
i love him
please yeah hit me hit me up anytime i
love being here this is
a worthy worthy worthy use of my time
and and we don't get to catch up yeah
outside of outside we're all working so
much you know so this is a great time
just to mix it up in a very casual
format and just you know share some
thoughts so it's beautiful being here
and i truly truly appreciate the invite
truly
yeah
yeah yeah i love these type of
discussion the intellectual talk and
it's just fun it's just fun and the
passion because like all of us here are
busy we all do a ton of things and it's
just fun to get together campfire and
talk about i go front like i'm excited
again i'm excited to get back into
destiny again i have my little vacation
kind of like physics now i gotta you
know dip my foot in see what's going on
with this 30th what's going on so but
yeah with me you already know i lower
cognito on twitter all that good stuff
defining dude please support that if you
can me and maddie been trying to kill it
with the episodes and kind of unique
takes on the gaming industry and what's
going on with xbox iron lords podcasts
every sunday the lord's day 11 a.m we
will have asa from journalists from game
on daily.com really good guy from
overseas he's putting out great content
so we'll have him in the realm and check
him out and uh yo hit that like button
y'all it's a good show today hit that
hit that like button in the campfire
putting out some good content man it's
real fun man so um i enjoyed doing it
and uh e what's going on with you and i
just want to pray for you for february
all your favorite games come out in
february and i just want to pray for you
and where all the tough decisions you're
gonna have to be
i am so sad about that time because
seriously i've been looking forward to
horizon zero dawn i got the monitor and
like okay i'm gonna play horizon zero
dawn on pc i wanted to look gorgeous
uh and then now horizon zero dawn comes
out four days before destiny i don't
want to like
not sleep enough to finish that game and
do it justice like 50 hours in a weekend
so then i'm like well crap and that's
gonna be
pushed off a little bit elden ring is
three days which is almost higher than
horizon at this point because it's
insane and that one you know you're
going to be playing destiny you know
you're going to be level time frame is
going to be nuts you're going to be my
god
you're going to level up you're ready
for the race all that stuff and i was
like and but i was like but i want to be
part of like elden ring when it's french
but i wanted a discussion yeah yeah it's
like horizon i'm just gonna miss but
it's a story and i'll get to it when i
get to it but i was like i'll play that
if i ever get some down but elden ring
is one of those like it's
there's moments there's moments in games
it's like playing pokemon go now versus
the summer it came out
that's the extreme example because yeah
you gotta be part of the zeitgeist man
gotta be part of it so it's like
we will be drinking lots of advanced
gigi focus use code
uh we got is yours what is yours
physically what is your code yep
physical physics that's what i thought
yep use code physics for tony um
i will probably be living on a little
bit of that probably more than i should
trying to sleep when i can
uh what's going on
no i'm saying in february because
there's no not enough time where you
play all the cameras yeah it's really
not it's really not uh but other than
that yeah it's like now that i got my
monitor and you know we're gonna see
what happens on tuesday i want to see if
i can knock out ratchet and clank before
i don't think it's going to be that long
but i was like i've been waiting to see
as pretty as that thing's going to look
but then it's like death stranding
horizon on pc
um
guardians like i got i got some other
stuff in my backlog now and we got a
good time for it so that's what i'm
looking forward to is setting that stuff
up and streaming that variety things
while still kind of working on destiny
in the background but i mean
we're gonna have some stuff to do but
it's only gonna it's not gonna be as big
as people i think think because it's a
lot of ornaments it's a dungeon and a
weapon but it's you know you're going to
run out and kind of get back to the
usual so
we will see but i mean lots of tv shows
to watch as well and i can't keep up
with all that i don't know how some
people can play all the games they do
and then
like have you watched this no have you
watched no like i just now started squid
games
just downstairs i just finished it cog i
was right there with you bro i'm so late
on everything it is
i would see references on twitter and i
didn't know what people would talk about
and i'm like oh this is why they was
dressed up like this this is what this
means like it was it was
definitely definitely
it lives up to it but my rule is unless
my hands are busy like i'm eating
something i'm not watching the show i'm
playing a video playing i'm not gonna
yeah so yeah that one's yeah when you
watch episode six um give me give me a
buzz because i'm one three one one three
they wallet right now yeah go let me
know and let me know when you finish six
and uh okay just send me a text i don't
care the hour six hours i want you i
want your true feelings after six yeah
okay um but yeah you guys know where to
find me if you guys do enjoy the shows
as they've said like the you know like
the podcast if you're in here live
listening if you guys are made it this
far in if you listen to us on itunes
listen to us on spotify if you listen to
us anywhere video or audio please you
know drop the reviews give the likes
whether it's on iron lord's podcast
channel if you want go to
lordsofgaming.net
go find travis's review and just leave a
fun comment for nerf
but i don't suggest you play it don't
buy the game
and see how well you can do there and
please please
go find this man physics tony hang out
in his community see what his community
is like hang out in his twitch streams
go join his discord
anything you can it's a good place to be
and it's a positive atmosphere so you
cannot go wrong hanging out with this
man
i appreciate it i appreciate it for the
right to get a little spicy i do get a
little spicy
we like the slices right now i love it a
little
sportsmanship and and just trying to
improve myself and share that with my
community so definitely absolutely for
the record the last word received the
buff with the glasses today i'm just
telling you i see the energy
we got a buff this week tell them
fair enough yeah that's that's what we
do these are blue light glasses but yeah
my vision's not perfect it's like what
20 35
so it's like i go from like i can see
mostly fine it's like or if i want to
see hi def that's like my dad oh travis
on fire i'm telling you
podcast next level yo
well thank you guys very much everybody
in chat you guys have been absolutely
fire uh tony sir again thank you travis
of course love to have you here and cog
my co-host who started flashpoint
somebody's like there's been two phases
they were like pre-travis and post
harvest and i was like
there was three because we were a
flashpoint before we were ever on the
campfire so shout out to scarole for
letting us get the nick
[Laughter]
we still have msnbc who could come down
on us but hopefully that doesn't happen
either but we don't know about that
different differences
we'll bring hogan off in the episode
we'll save yourself you have to pay
scarab royalties is that part of the
deal here
get the rules yeah uh when i order my
advanced gg i use code scare note
[Laughter]
thank you guys so much for this episode
number 175 december 2nd as we wrap up
2021 we are almost done
no
no yes yes
no put the hands down
put them down
no
this is not a thing you can have your
longest running segment
you can't have this one
if you aren't watching the video you
have no idea what we're talking about
but anyways as we wrap this one up thank
you guys very much this episode it has
been
the last word